Hello gamers!
Oh my god.
Why did I get a cough drop?
I think it was the coffee.
Oh.
Nope.
Nummy.
Coffee.
I had coffee because I woke up early.
Well, I didn't really wake up that early this morning.
But I had two me and greets.
I was at Vexpo and now here I am.
Wait, let me move my cursor.
There we go.
Playing Metal Gear Solid Delta.
Yeah, I think that I can use...
I think I don't have to be Chibi Minto.
So far, so good.
I don't think...
Can I sing along?
Can we do a sing along real quick?
Wait.
What did I do with the wrap?
for her.
Wait, did I throw it away?
With darkness and silence through the night.
I love this part.
What a thrill.
She's so into it.
I love it.
I'm searching and I'll melt into you.
What a fear in my heart.
But you're so supreme.
In
my time, there'll be no one else.
Crime, it's the way I fly to you.
I'm still in a dream, snake eat up.
Please sleep.
Someday you go through the rain.
Oh gosh, we're about to go against the fear, huh?
And someday you'll plead on a tree frog.
This ordeal, the trial to survive.
We see new life.
In my time, there'll be no one else.
Crime, it's the way I fight to you.
I'm still in a dream.
Snake eater
I'm still in a dream Snake eater Bye bye bye
Yeah baby, yeah baby, yeah baby Yeah, baby, yeah baby, yeah baby shows that we're in the Grinini Gorky.
Wait.
Oh, I am still in Grinini Gorky.
I forgot.
Having fun with my playthrough.
Thank you!
See what I'm doing.
I got around to playing MGS 1 and 2 so I could play Delta.
Ooh!
Nice.
Cynthia the Go.
I saw someone.
Yeah, I went on a rampage.
No, that didn't save, though.
I don't.
I don't think so.
But, um, I saw a...
I saw, um, someone, while the song was happening, being like, these lyrics don't make much sense.
Yes, they do.
It's literally a song, The Boss to Snake.
They make the most sense.
Someday you do feed on a tree frog.
It's in the game!
That's life, baby!
This ordeal, the trial, to survive!
I mean, when I take the lyrics, literally.
I think actually the song, like, makes the most sense.
I'll take your word for it.
It's in there!
Okay, let me take my...
Let me eat my cough drop again.
Cool!
Um, we just...
We just said nice shoes.
And now we, um...
We are continuing onward.
I'm actually surprised you saw my comment.
I read a little bit.
bit sometimes don't know so you can buy a tasty tree frog for a snack boss you thank you thank you maybe you're a thrill I think we're thrilling it up today I'm just gonna play for however long I want to play so VOD watchers will know the length if you're watching the VOD hello write a comment say I'm watching the VOD
But, uh...
Do you hear me?
Of course!
But, um...
Eight hours streaming coming.
I really don't know, I really can't say.
I'm just gonna, like I said, I'm gonna play for however long I want to.
I'd like to get...
I'm not gonna say, because I don't wanna...
I don't wanna... I don't wanna... What's the word?
I don't wanna think about it.
Cody!
Happy early birthday, happy early birthday!
Sneeter button is R1.
Oh, wait, really?
Should I load again?
Probably continue is fine.
My last save point.
This is probably fine.
Okay, okay, we're fine, we're fine.
My murderous rampage is over.
Wait.
It is over, right?
Oh, okay, wait, hold on, I have to remember the controls again.
This is, okay, there we go.
Let's put on our, we got our glasses.
Let's put on our scientist outfit.
Turn it up a little bit.
I want it blasting in my ears.
Okay, sorry, okay.
Oh!
Come on, sit in here!
Oh, nasty snake!
Okay.
I think if we just run through here, we'll be fine.
Oh gosh.
Don't notice me?
Run away?
Go away?
Yeah?
Okay, sit down.
Oh!
How did they all notice me, I was?
Wait, wait, get up, get up, stick.
Wait, how do I...
Oh my god.
Wait, I'm trying to get into the menu so I can change out of my clothes.
Oh, it won't let me into the menu!
Wait, can you not go into the menu when you're...
How do they know?
Okay.
Oh.
Wait, I want to put on my hat.
How do I...
Oh, that's cute.
I'm suffering from a deep cut, everybody.
I'm very offended.
How did they know so fast?
Where's my bleeding?
Oh, here we go.
Oh.
Let me put on my hat.
Is it...
Oh, no.
I have to equip it.
That's right.
Oh.
Oh, gosh.
Wait, I don't remember the controls.
Wait, how do I equip anything?
Oh my gosh.
Why can't I remember the controls anymore?
Hold on, please!
Ow!
Oh, well.
Okay, hold on.
Everybody, please!
My buttons aren't working!
Is it R?
It's on the T-pad.
Okay, anyway, we're fine.
I remember
everything now?
All I need to do is leave?
No?
Help me!
Oh, oh, shoot.
Oh, come on, good up, Snake.
Okay, good warm-up, everybody.
Where is it start me at?
No, kidding!
Wow.
Okay, wait, this is actually awesome.
Let's go back to being a scientist.
Wait, I'm still cutting.
Wait, how did it... How...
Sorry, I can't stop laughing.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, we're fine.
Everything's fine.
I think Minto is ready for European Extreme.
Yes?
excuse me excuse me I need to leave your facilities okay everything's fine everybody this is European extreme wait you can't see me right or you're not supposed to see me rather I don't want you to see me
yeah all right and put my hat back on just a crocodile wait why can't I move
okay oh my gosh I'm like oh okay I'm just a crocodile where are
oh there he is and there's another but I'm a crocodile they'll never see me drop off nice oh okay oh dang it's so extreme there we go
i'm obsessed i'm obsessed with all like everything that people are doing with the croc hat for every cut scene i think it might be the best way to play this game ever not gonna lie I'm a standing croc.
Does he have a... I've been trying to find like tapes but...
Oh wait!
Oh my food!
Oh!
It's all right!
The calorie mate's good though.
Good old calorie mate.
I want some more!
Oops, I'll rot in.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Why can't I remember where to go?
Do I need to just...
Where was it?
Is it where I came from?
I want some more.
Let's go where I came from.
What a lovely day.
It'll be a crocodile.
Whenever I think about the non-lethal train, I think about the poor guards you accidentally hit in the iron mouth while yawning.
I don't.
I don't think about that at all.
Granini Gorky.
Such a fun name to say.
Is there a guy over here?
Am I crazy?
I am the most stealth man ever though right now.
a crocodile there's no way they can know
two seconds before they know oh no no oh I bet that is a joke
this crocodile is ah don't yeah a red and yellow friend of fellow
this dog i don't think he's gonna care about me at all because i have a croc hat on don't care about me dog oh but this guy i think he's gonna notice me i have 80 90 percent there's no way yeah whatever wait he might see me if i'm walking though there's an achievement for getting over a hundred percent or is it a hundred percent stealth I kind of want it does that croc have a gun I don't have the gun also I think they would do that it's a new Russian experiment crocs with guns I think it's actually very something that they would do
no you don't think It's advanced!
Nobody would want to mess with a crocodile, with a gun!
Me being like...
Me being like, oh my gosh, how did they know last time I streamed this game?
When I was like, hey, oh my gosh, look at the little leaf covering his nip.
Look, do you see it?
Wait, zoom in.
Enhanced?
Not his crotch?
There we go.
Oh, it's gone!
Why does this keep happening to me?
Anyway, it got clipped from me being like, how would they know that I'm a crocodile?
Because I look so much like a crocodile.
And people were like, it's because she said crocodile.
And not this very, this other, whatever the gator is actually called.
Not gator, you know what I mean.
Whatever he's at.
The long snout.
whatever what oh this way something something and i just want to say to those haters it's literally called the crocodile cap so you guys can shut the hell up gabriel yeah you know what who got it wrong hideo kojima do you want to say that to him do you want to say hideo kojima got it wrong i'm calling it what it's called in the game yes i will oh no here he is
I have a secret to tell you guys.
I ended last stream where I did because I didn't want to fight the fear.
I was like, I don't think I'm ready to deal with this guy right now.
Knew it!
I was like, I don't think I want to fight the fear right now.
That's my secret.
Come on, Crock, you got this!
Oh, whoa, with the stout going.
Yeah!
First boss, did you forget about the pain?
What about...
What about us a lot?
Oh, my God.
Your limbs will be paralyzed.
Your lungs...
What about my snout?
Ah, what a fun with that.
Hey, uh, step out of it.
The boss is the apprentice.
I will give you fear such as you've never experienced before.
Come into my web.
Whoa.
I hate what he does.
Are you ready to kill me?
okay there we go you've been shot with a poison bolt the poison is spreading throughout your body your life is going to keep decreasing unless you do something about it hurry and neutralize the poison yes mom go into the survival viewer and use cure to give yourself a serum injection the serum will neutralize the poison but don't forget to treat the bolt wound itself as well to treat a bolt wound you'll need your knife a stiptic and a disinfectant a pee on it use your knife to dig out the bolt and then apply stiptic and disinfectant to the wound follow those steps and the wound should heal right up now start the treatment hurry okay okay wait wait wait they made him stinky
look at them cankles
Smelly Gator Smelly Crocodile Sorry, I keep saying Gator That one I actually will say no It's not a Gator at all
Smelly, smelly Smelly, smelly Just throw up the poison, throw it up Gow, go, go, go, go, go Go, go, go, go, go Gassius Gator No, no Oh, he's a crock!
Okay.
I'm suffering from venom poisoning.
I might actually die.
So what, I have to...
Excerpt...
Serum.
And then we gotta get the bolt out.
There it is.
Okay, and we're bleeding.
And we're disinfecting.
Oh, shoot, I used...
Oh, wait, bleeding!
Oh, how...
Wait.
Ah, this...
I used two on action.
I can't read.
Oh, gotcha.
Okay.
Actually, kind of...
Oh, I...
I see you.
Oh, gee, I'll just...
I'll just...
Oh, I can't hit either.
Okay, I got him.
He's actually quite easy to see.
Oh, I say that, and now I lost him.
He's good.
Oh, boy, yeah.
Are you still there?
Okay.
Yeah.
It's actually, like, so easy to see.
Like, it's actually so easy to see.
Okay, monkey.
Yeah, actually.
Okay.
Wait, this is way too easy, I fear.
Wait, it's...
Oh, you!
Ah!
Shoot.
Oh, he's gone.
It's like so...
Wait, it's actually so easy.
How did I get hit?
Uh, uh, uh, disinfect.
Oh, we're fine.
Okay.
I don't want to get...
Wait, okay, how do I do?
Okay, photo mode.
Oh wait, um, where's my...
Where's, uh...
Let's see.
In my backpack.
Let's give him a...
How do I throw the food?
Wait, let's give him like a poison dart frog.
No, no, no.
Uh, add to my backpack.
Oh, it's probably under a weapon.
There we go.
Okay.
We'll give them a bat.
We're just gonna give the guy a bat.
There you go.
Hungry.
Hungry?
Eat that!
No, no, no, mister!
Wait.
This might be a great time to take a photo.
Woo!
Yeah!
Here we go.
It's so good.
Wow!
Wait, this is so awesome!
I've been meaning to take more photos.
But I keep forgetting.
Um.
Oh, here we go.
Hide.
What is it?
F12?
There we go.
Yeah!
Wait, this is so good!
my spit wrong.
I'm fine.
Okay.
We're fine.
I've been wanting to take more photos, though.
You think he'll eat that, or...
Wait, what's that?
That's not mine.
Oh.
Yes!
You ate it!
Stupid!
Dummy!
Wait, I'm hungry.
Or is that him?
What is mine at?
No, I'm thinking I'm fine.
Did he just throw it up?
Oh my gosh, he scared me now.
He's so fast.
He's...
He's so stinking fast.
Oh.
Oh, did I get him?
Oh, I did.
Nice.
This fight is like crazy easy.
I don't know what I was worried about.
I was worried that he would be easy to see in the...
Actually, I don't know where he is now.
In the high death, you know.
Oh, oh, oh my gosh.
Oh, now he's back to normal.
Wait, ah.
Oh, come on, Snake!
Hurry up!
Oh!
Where is he?
I don't know where he went.
Oh, no, I lost him.
Ah, I'm trying to leave.
I lost him, though.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, I just lost him.
I lost him.
There he is.
Oh, now he recovered!
I just noticed.
Oh, my God.
He healed.
Ah, it was too late.
You bastard.
Wait, where are you?
Oh, my gosh.
Don't you.
Oh, he's healed so much!
Oh, God.
Everything is bad.
I'm too slow.
Where is he?
It was supposed to be easy.
Wait, I have so much...
Oh, wrong button.
I have so much bad food.
Let's, like, put it all in here.
All in, baby.
All in.
Okay, all my bad food for him.
Russian bat...
Everything, everything is nasty.
Everything is bad.
No, my glow caps!
It's a food fight, yeah.
If food is what he wants, food is what he'll get.
Ah!
I'm still burned.
I have more arrows in the head?
Holy cow.
How am I alive?
OP.
Snake has protag power.
Holy cow.
Let's eat another.
When did I get this frog?
Yep, loco maloco.
We'll eat it.
His skull is just that thick.
It's true.
Yaboko and mimoko.
Yaboko.
Ah!
Dang, we were so close.
I was like literally one hit away.
Oh well.
That's fine.
I might die.
If so, I don't care.
Oh, uh, let's throw our bat.
I got my bat.
I got my bat!
Wait.
Oh, I have to...
Dang it, I have to throw him back into my...
We're, like, not really doing well.
Oh,
my gosh.
If I could aim, it would be great.
I can't see anything because of the red.
Oh.
Okay, go.
Get him in the butt.
One more, maybe.
Gamer hay.
The fear!
I see it!
FAH!
Crazy!
I wonder if you'll be able to see those.
That'd be so fun.
The fear!
I see no bolts.
Spitter.
I got birdie oh get it birdie I got a book
my health could be better maybe we should grab some stuff while we're here like a bunny okay time to get lethal everybody time to get lethal my river will be full of bunnies hunting season.
Sorry, I've missed so many super chats, but thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you so much.
I really appreciate it.
We'll take that.
Oh, wait.
Nah, we're doing non-nuclear.
Tail is too small.
Snake needs a fatter tail.
Zero out of 10 unplayable.
Oh, my God.
You can't please anybody these days.
There we go.
Where'd that bunny go?
Oh, sweet rabbit.
There you are.
Lunch.
Where'd the gako go?
Those are.
This is the Yaboko Momoko.
This is a mystery.
Or it's our fruit.
Wait.
Actually, I'm not sure what I just got.
Sparkle?
I thought he was in this tree here.
I think I was mistaken.
Let's see what food we got.
Oh, yeah.
Not
so great.
Not so great.
We haven't eaten the rabbit yet.
Yeah, hold on, let's call a paramedic and see how it tastes.
I see you've captured a magpie.
Magpies are members of the crow family.
They're distinguishable by their beautiful dark blue and white bodies and their long tails.
Their favorite food is insects, but they'll also eat small fish, acorns, and fruit.
They're omnivores, which means...
They'll eat anything.
Right, just like you, huh?
Like a stuffy nose?
Okay, so how do they taste?
You always ask me that.
Naturally.
so I've never heard of anybody actually eating a magpie but I suppose there's no reason you couldn't you don't say I see you've caught a European rabbit yes the European rabbit is said to have come from the Mediterranean region originally but nowadays they're found all over the world they've been used since ancient times as a source of food so it might be worth catching them rabbits are known to eat their own excrement.
They eat their own...
That's right.
It's called sickle feces.
When the rabbit eats fibers, the fiber is fermented in the rabbit's appendix or secum and turned into a nutritious substance full of vitamins.
The rabbit excretes the substance and then eats it again to absorb the nutrients.
That's a neat trick.
I think I'll give it a try.
Snake, rabbits and humans don't work that...
I'm just kidding.
You really thought I was going to eat it?
A little, yeah.
You mean I wouldn't do that.
I guess not.
But how did those single feces taste?
What?
I'm just kidding.
He's such a trickster.
Snake.
Alright, let's eat some rabbit.
Actually, I don't think we need to eat all of it.
We'll just eat the mango.
We'll save that for when we're hungry.
Pretty tasty.
He's such a goofy guy.
isn't he?
Where did the bird go?
Gakko, gakko, gakko.
Hold on, let's try from over here.
I lost him.
Maybe I have to climb up this tree.
Climb, climb.
Oh!
Big boy.
There he is.
Oh wait, he's already spinning.
I got this one.
Did I get Kero-Tan in here then?
Um.
Hmm.
What was shining right there?
Maybe I didn't get Kero-Tan.
Hello.
He's so cute.
I meant Stiffy.
Miffy.
Miffy the rabbit.
I love Miffy.
And boars.
Wait, I see!
Oh, Kero-Tan's also twirling.
Just kidding, I got this area.
Passed out to your Half-Life 2 stream yesterday.
Is it a bad thing?
Am I cooked falling asleep to Oshi playing games?
Why is that a bad thing?
I have streamers that I like that I fall asleep to their streams all the time.
I put them on for sleep.
I don't think that's a bad thing.
Is it?
Give me the mushroom!
Okay.
Hold on.
I'm trying to remember how to...
How to roll.
No.
I can't...
Oh, okay.
I found out.
And good thing I dodged that.
I almost...
I almost rolled right into a trap.
Is this where the Tsichinoko is?
One of the places?
No, I think about it.
Is this where one of them is?
Like, one of the...
I think there's...
Oops.
Dang it.
I gotta get all my stuff again.
Ah, I gotta get all my stuff again.
Ah!
I fell for a loser trap.
That was so lame!
I just noticed also I should equip the...
Not the chaff.
Look at this.
Okay.
I fell for it.
Quite literally.
We're gonna eat this bird instead of capture it because there's no point in not eating something.
No, get up, Snake.
There you go.
Get your book.
Don't fall into that.
Get the rabbit.
Oops.
Eat the rabbit.
I'll eat the rabbit.
Walk right into that one.
Hey, this works.
Oh, that was great.
There we go.
All right, we should.
Then what else was there?
There was something.
over here.
Sorry, guys.
I didn't mean to fall into it.
Where?
I can't remember the Tsuchinoko like, proper location.
Where the little guy is at.
I just know he's a really fat guy.
Oh!
I didn't even see that one.
How did I avoid it twice?
Wow.
Your Honor, she's a gamer.
I stepped right on the edge, but I didn't even see it before either.
Craziness.
Um, hold on, let me check the map again.
Okay, yeah.
What's the green checkmark?
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay.
I'm going to collect a little bit more food.
Like some...
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Some mushrooms?
Mushroom sea?
Mushroom dew?
Maybe it's...
Ah, I can't remember at all where the...
There's another trap right there!
Grab some rabbit.
Wabbit hunting season.
Oh,
barely.
No, my food is full!
Okay, we're gonna have to get rid of something.
My Russian glow crab.
Congratulations.
Oh.
First winner of both Felford Award and almost Felford Award.
Oh,
my batteries.
There we go.
Okie dokie.
Or the Choki.
I really want to see a Tsuchinoko one day.
In the game.
Real life is kind of whatever.
But I want to see one in the game, you know?
I want to see that big fat guy just kind of crawling around.
I want to see that.
They're really...
They have like such tiny bodies and it's just really round.
Tsuchinoko real!
It's in the game.
It's here.
It's real.
They are cute, right?
The whole codec team finds over it.
I know!
I want to see!
And then, paramedics like, Don't you dare eat it!
I can't help it.
If I'm hungry, I mean...
Okay.
Onward!
Thank you.
Snake is always hungry.
Oh, I went the wrong way.
I got too interested in Lil Tsuchinoko.
I forgot completely.
I have a friend named Apache.
He's a MGS3.
He's a Metal Gear Speedrunner.
And he can do this game literally.
Actually, like, when I say he can play this game blindfolded, like I'm not exaggerating.
Like, he plays it blindfolded.
But this area scares me the most.
Like after you finish the fear, how do you know where you are to avoid all the traps, you know?
Yeah, he's really good.
I recommend his playthroughs.
He's played for like GTQ.
I remember where we're going.
Um, I will leave my camouflage for this room.
What if...
Wait, what does spider give me again?
Where stealth at the cost of stamina?
It's not...
Webby enough for me.
I don't know.
It's not webby enough.
But we got more stealth.
Drain- how- let's see how much stamina it does drain.
I guess we would need like food after food after food after food.
And my hat.
Sorry, crock hat.
Nah, it's fine.
Oh, I see it going down.
So fast.
Do
you see that?
That's crazy.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, never mind.
That's insane.
We'll go back to...
I like how nothing else compares We'll go back to the Peace Walker outfit
Oh, it looks so good It looks so good There was one thing So actually it's with This outfit So this outfit is also In Ground zeros but in that the text here you see the text on the gold on his arm and on his thigh it's not there even though it's supposed like it's this is it originally was on the on the peace walker one but in ground zeros they didn't include it but in this game they do include it so this one is actually more accurate to Peace Walker.
It's not just like a port from the other game.
It's actually like...
What's it say?
I don't know.
My suppressor is on, right?
Oh, I'm already hungry.
Wait, my suppressor's on, right?
I love the music.
It's so good.
Tune, tune, tune, tune.
Oh, we saw him get hit.
Where is he?
Hello?
Are you gonna go investigate your friend?
Are we gonna do anything?
Time to eat.
I'll eat.
of.
Oh, we didn't eat the bird.
Gross.
Okay, it's not good.
We'll eat the rabbit.
You never liked that guy?
I do know about blowing up the food supply.
I can't tell if some guy is coming up or not.
I can't tell what the AI is doing it all.
I don't know, actually.
Oh, there he goes.
Oh, my gosh.
What's wrong?
Hello?
Is nobody gonna investigate?
What's wrong?
I don't know.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, shoot.
Come on, sleep!
be sleepy there we go i was kind of terrible but it's fine now where's our other guy hello
no one worry about the oh shoot you don't see me there we go I think that's, yeah.
Hang.
And drop.
Oh my gosh.
I can't remember.
Even though it tells me.
There we go.
Thank you.
Uh, I need to go through that door.
Third time's the charm.
Give me your stuff.
Wait.
I want a crab.
Be careful of that guy.
You're doing everywhere but the crab?
Oh, my bad.
Okay, don't worry about it.
We'll eat right.
Oh, I
didn't actually remember the crabs.
I think they're not very good, but whatever.
The rat.
The pekoro made famous.
Let's not have this out.
There we go.
Oh, no, I meant it to change.
Good thing the crab isn't one of the bosses.
Hear me, snake.
Wait, wait, hold on.
Let me call, actually.
see what she says about it i see you've caught yourself a kenyan mangrove crab yeah the kenyan mangrove crab is a land-going crab it lives in burrows dug near seashores and mangrove swamps the spots a mushroom next to the tree here might hurt a little bit it attacks you with its pinchers thank you mcmack i'll look i'll grab it wait did she say it's poisonous i see you caught yourself a rat yep the rats in that area are the descendants of wild norway rats that were domesticated by humans as pets and lab animals.
Grab battle.
They're not poisonous, and I don't think they'll attack you, but they're quick little creatures, so you might have a hard time catching one.
I got it.
I got the red.
We're not so hungry.
Okay, wait, there's a...
I...
Eva.
Snake, are you there?
Eva, where are you?
Sorry, I was like, I'm spoiling it.
Dr. Sokolov is here too.
Is he all right?
He's fine.
Right now he's busy putting the finishing touches on the Shagohad.
Good.
That means they haven't killed him.
Not yet anyway, but you better hurry.
They've already finished the phase two tests.
Once the final preparations are complete, they'll have no more use for him.
The Colonel won't have any qualms about killing him if he thinks the CIA is closing in.
Eva, you can't let Sokolov out of your sight.
Oh, really?
I know.
Snake, do you know where Groznygrad is?
Groznygrad is.
Granin told me that I should be able to get there from the mountains to the north, through an underground tunnel.
Granin told you?
Yeah, he even gave me the key to the warehouse.
Why?
Because he was drunk, I guess.
You've got to be kidding me.
Hell if I know.
Snake, there's one problem with that route.
What problem?
The mountain entrance to the underground tunnel that leads to the fortress is sealed.
You need a key to get in.
A key?
What about the key Granin gave me?
That key won't work.
but don't worry I'll figure something out okay I have an idea there are some ruins at the top of the mountains meet me there the top of the mountains got it wait there's something else I've got to tell you now what I heard that one of the cobras is waiting for you in the jungle at the foot of the mountains he's a legendary sniper called the end yeah I've seen him before grandpa that ridiculously old guy right don't underestimate him Hebeyo!
He's known as the father of modern sniping.
Is he alone?
No spotter?
None.
He's all by himself.
Apparently he doesn't need a spotter.
You can't be serious.
The entire forest is on his side.
The forest?
Stay alert.
Yeah.
I'd hate to have it be the end for me.
Good one, Snake.
Did I just see blue feathers?
Huh.
Hey, B-O.
Yeah, he's like right over there.
Let's see.
Got ourselves a book?
Who's reading out here, huh?
Oh, no.
Oh, these ones.
On mission today, so I'll have to catch up later.
No worries.
Thanks for dropping by.
Thanks, insanity.
Oh, oh, my food.
I forgot my food is full.
We can eat.
We can eat the mushrooms.
They're, like, so little.
Oh.
What is this?
I thought they were little.
Wait, before it, like, offered such little amount.
What is there?
Oh, it's the bird.
Oh, that's a...
I thought that was a tail.
he is oh wait no he's not over there he's over okay hold on um did i get it do anyone any oh let's search for gako kero time don't bully the elderly um no promises i think
kero time is still surprisingly difficult because the land is actually It's actually quite green and lush.
And Kero-tan?
What?
Wait!
The tree!
He looks just like the tree!
No!
Wait!
That's so funny.
Look at the tree sticking his arms out too!
i actually kind of like the legacy well actually it looks bad here usually it looks all right i wish legacy and action movie were like in between you know wait there we go there we go a posing snake that's anytime i do mocap a pose i'm so used to a poses now Well,
I don't see him, you guys.
Kero-Tad!
Even Gako here.
Maybe he's just not around.
Oh, whoops.
Ay.
I don't remember how to get to the regular screen.
So I've just been pushing the down button I see you found a bichal scaly tooth the bichal scaly tooth mushroom is used as an antidote to poison it usually grows on the trunks of trees so look for it no help how does it taste I think you're going to be disappointed damn oh quit your whining you know what they say good medicine tastes bitter oh it's like the spots is near the top of this map okay thank you um it's a Oh gosh,
like that, there's like the, what's it called medicine, the, um, like the headache medicine that is better as a powder.
All right, a little bunny.
No, my food is faux.
Throw out some more Russian glow caps.
So sad.
I don't really use it anyway.
I don't really use the batteries.
But I want to keep the stuff that I can poison people with.
I guess I don't need this guy either.
Well, well, he doesn't take up anything.
And this guy, he's not dead, so they won't eat him.
Well, they get scared of him, I don't know.
Vivicore, thanks for the gift, dude!
No, there's like a headache medicine that's like a powder form and it's so bitter.
Why are you guys saying weird?
You guys are like, okay?
No!
What's wrong with you?
Oh, I did eat this crab before.
Said not to be very good.
Contains poison neutralizing properties.
Okay, we got the rabbit.
Rabbit, rabbit.
I don't want to...
Oh, this...
Oh, yeah.
Is it this guy?
Okay.
is it this one get handker what oh no i have the cigarette i don't have the handkerchief
i see you've caught a european rabbit the european rabbit is a different rabbit from the mediterranean region originally but nowadays we've listened to this one and then i died i remember i see you found a spaza spaza Spots are right interesting name spa hmm hmm huh so paramedic what what kind of mushroom is a Spots are you really want to know I guess so okay let's see the Spots are yeah it's gray hmm and it grows on the ground yeah And...
That's all.
That's all?
That's all the guide says.
Okay, so I don't know that much about it.
Why don't you eat one and see?
It might be pretty tasty.
Eat one and see?
What do I look like, a lab rat?
Shh!
What did I say?
What if the rats hear you?
You'll hurt their feelings.
Why is she so weird sometimes?
Why is she... Why are you...
Why are they so weird?
I feel like it's one of those kinds of things that, like, just gets translated a little bit funny.
I'm not quite sure.
Like with, like, an MGS2 nerd and node.
Like, it makes no sense in English.
Spa.
I don't see them.
I'm just gonna go.
I love how goofy this game is.
Oh my gosh, I've gotten so many TikToks about, like, I don't, actually, surprisingly, I don't get very metal, very many Metal Gear TikToks, even though I watch a lot of Metal Gear TikToks.
But lately, I've been getting a bunch of people playing this game for the first time, and they're like, it's every single one of the clips are about Ocelot and, like, his gun twirling and people reacting to it for the first time.
And I'm like, wow, I was literally there just like a couple years ago.
It's kind of crazy!
Master Ghost, happy birthday!
Eating it gives another codec.
Oh!
Well, I'll eat it when I have my health or my hunger a little bit more.
Thank you, though.
I will eat it.
Aren't there guys here?
Or am I crazy?
Aren't there guys before the end?
I don't remember.
I don't think I'm crazy.
I think there are.
oh i do remember okay i know where i am it's so weird seeing these maps sometimes and this hd i missed your first hour of your stream can you please rewind to the beginning okay like there's some guys up there if i remember correctly i'm a gator it's fine
where are they mr men's where are you Thank you.
Robin?
Three months sweet.
Froggy!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, he's looking right at me.
Wait, my camo is like so bad.
That's not what I meant to do.
My camo should be 100%, what are they talking about?
What are they talking about?
I have to go so far.
Literally a crocodile.
If you ignore the gun.
See, now I'm 90.
I don't understand.
Wait, hold on.
Let me look at the map again.
Okay, we're just going forward.
Okay.
Onwards.
Wait, this way?
I'm getting lost.
This way.
I was like, this looks like the correct way.
Move out of the way, birds.
I'm crawling through here as a gator.
I'm just gatoring it up.
I don't care anymore.
I'm a gator.
I'm...
Oh, shoot.
Nothing?
Just a crocodile?
I'm not a gator.
Don't call me that.
Don't call me a gator.
That's not my name.
I'm a crock.
Do you think they can hear the rubber?
Can you guys hear it?
Can you guys?
How's the volume, by the way?
For some reason, the game seems really quiet today.
I've turned it up like all the way.
I hear more bees.
Dirty!
It's good?
Thank you!
Where are we?
I'm going the wrong way.
I gotta go.
What is over there?
I don't remember.
Oh wait!
Is over there like that house?
I think.
It's like a little house.
Hello?
There we go.
Let's reload.
I can't remember.
Yeah, I can't remember the button though.
Ah!
I love this cutscene.
No!
I love this scene though.
Yo!
Crocodiles weirdly kicked up.
Hello?
Do you hear me say...
Woo!
I beg of you.
Grant me the strength to take this final prey.
Let me linger in this world just a little longer.
I have already slept enough for one lifetime.
Enough for an eternity.
you have my thanks i feel like this fight is gonna be pretty tricky i have to thank you for waking me if you hadn't shown up my sleep i'm doing non-lethal for every would have been eternal
you hear me snake I am the end I am here to send you to your ultimate fate you'll make a fine quarry for my final hunt I love the end so much so cool so cool
I found that sniper you were talking about.
So cool.
That's the end.
He's a legend.
Known as the father of sniping.
Do you hear me sniping?
I've got experience sniping in urban and marine environments.
What about the forest?
Never.
I see.
Well, that forest is divided into three areas.
I love, I love, I love the end.
Oh my gosh.
He should be lying in wait for you in one of those places.
Sounds like this may take a while.
It'll be a test of endurance.
Be careful though.
Okay.
From what I've heard, the End has an almost supernatural knack for camouflaging himself.
Such a good fight.
I know!
Okay.
This guy's over a hundred years old, though.
So I should have the advantage in terms of stamina.
People have tried that, right?
Or I wouldn't be so sure if I were you.
Why is that?
I've heard that his body is photosynthetic.
Like a plant?
What is he?
Some kind of monster?
On top of that, he can speak to the forest too.
So in other words, he knows it inside out.
Wait, is actually still a thing?
But he doesn't know you.
I'm sure you can beat him.
Don't worry.
I intend to.
Just wait it out real time.
I'm a croc.
Okay.
Alright.
The battle begins, everybody.
The battle begins!
Where's my mic?
I do have it, right?
Uh...
Can you stop praying for my grandpa?
He's when he goes...
Wait, what?
Half...
He's waking up so he can unalive one half of my OTP BB...
What the hell?
What?
I don't have a mic.
Okay, cool.
Um...
Cool?
Is it under weapons?
Let me just see.
That'd be so bad.
Thank goodness.
Oh my goodness.
I was gonna say.
This sucks.
We'll never find him ever.
I hear the squeaking of mine.
I don't think he's in this area.
My camo is being 10%.
Literally an alligator.
I mean a crocodile.
What's wrong with me?
Why do I keep saying...
It's so much easier to say alligator than crocodile to me for some reason.
Yep.
Oh my gosh.
I can't tell at all how to see him.
Uh-oh.
I was worried about this fight.
I'm not gonna lie.
Why?
Is this...
I don't see like...
his scope, you know?
I wonder how it...
Well, you can try the thermals.
I don't know if it'll be too ugly.
We'll see.
Oh, I did have a clip.
I'm stupid.
Oh!
Ugh!
I didn't see the ref...
I saw...
Like, it was, like, definitely shining something.
There was like some light, but it was not like the little flash of light that I'm used to.
So I honestly don't know how to see him.
The thermal showed?
I don't know if that's him or not.
That just looks like plants to me.
Put the mic back on, see if he's...
He might have left this area.
Where the hell was he?
His stamina?
Oh, wait.
That's my stamina.
I'm stupid.
But his stamina is also getting lower.
I was like, his stamina is so low.
That's me.
I'm like, stand tall.
I hear something.
How does this happen?
No, it's not reload.
Wait.
Why isn't it reloading?
Oh, wait.
I only have four bullets left?
Oh, I'm so screwed.
Wait.
Uh-oh.
Wait, you guys, if I only have four bullets, I think I'm in trouble.
I only have four bullets left.
I should have raided the warehouse.
Oh, I see.
Got go up there.
Oh, no.
Oh, CQC time with the old man!
Was it you?
Oh, jeez.
I do have the smoke, yeah.
The sig spray.
No, we heard Kero-tan.
Oh, bako bako.
Wait, maybe there's some more in here.
TNT?
Please.
Ah!
Okay, okay, okay, good, good, good.
Okay, we got a little bit more.
Just a tiny bit.
We're so back.
Okay, if he were here, I feel like...
Well, okay.
Actually, let's put on the camel...
Which one is it?
Sounds of footsteps.
This one, too?
No.
Or naked woodland.
Gold?
Yeah, let's put on gold.
It's so terrible.
It's just so bad.
I can't get over it.
Like, his lips look so chapped in it.
I don't know what it is.
You love it?
Okay.
Um,
here's something.
Okay.
I'm Mito.
Hello!
Holy...
Oh, my god, it's...
Butt!
So sorry.
Sorry, I keep going back into the menu.
Uh, we'll eat this guy.
Pretty tasty.
Ahaya!
Okay.
Let's go this way.
It's raining.
This is good.
He can't heal, but we're not doing anything either.
Throw away your expired stuff.
No, no, no.
We can throw it at people.
And they'll eat it and get sick.
Oh, gosh!
We're just getting started.
You're making this too easy.
I hear him here.
Oh, I hear him running.
Oh my gosh.
Red snake!
Go faster!
Where'd he go?
How was he so fast?
Here?
Oh my
gosh, I see him.
Wait, uh, ah!
Oh my god, oh man!
I hear a goat.
Oh my god!
This is so bad.
You son of a...
There he is.
What am I...
Oh, I have a...
I have a couple tranquilizers in my head.
We're about to fall asleep.
Where'd he go?
Yeah, I know.
Oh, I lost him.
I lost him!
Ah!
Oh, gosh.
Hey, this works.
Yeah, we might need to put on the thermals for following him.
Actually...
So sorry for your eyes.
Is that him right there?
Yes.
Yes it is.
I have to walk up on him and freeze him.
Okay.
Yeah, I gotta hold him up.
He's like right in front of me, isn't he?
I'm always so nervous about doing this though because I suck at holding people up.
It's okay.
You'll find him in the end.
He breathed?
Where did you?
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Oh.
Where'd he go?
He's so freaking fast.
I think he's hiding up on this hill now.
Yes.
There he is.
Nope, that's a goat.
No, that's a goat.
I thought it was him.
It's a goat.
He might still be in this area, though.
Let's, uh, wait.
I saw something down there, Moo.
Oh, a bunny?
Dang it.
Oh my gosh.
Kero-Tanjis!
Stop!
Uh-oh.
It's beginning sunny again.
Sorry.
Oh gosh, it was so violent.
Oh, it's foggy.
I don't think he's here, you guys.
I think he left, maybe.
Oh, that's not what I wanted to do.
Uh...
I'm out, like, straight in the open if he is here.
Oh.
Wake up.
I don't think he's here.
Ah!
Go!
There we go.
Okay.
Get out, get out.
...
Boom!
Oh, it's like full sunny!
Oh, finally out of the womb.
Congratulations!
Thank you so much, though.
Hope, Xenoblade.
Thank you.
Oh, we're back here again.
Be very, very quiet.
No!
It's so funny.
Maybe I should go this way.
Should you eat this parrot right in front of him?
No!
There's only a few here.
Also, how do you do this fight?
Blindfolded.
It's absolutely insane.
Oh, he found him.
He's here.
I heard him.
But where are you?
I heard him, though.
He's like over there, this way?
Oh.
I'm gonna go to Crazy Camel.
Let's do...
Plus 20!
That's insane!
Wait.
Maybe the face too.
Thermals?
Oh, thermals!
Yes, thank you.
Ah!
Is that him?
You can see it!
You see a sniper!
Oh, it does!
It does!
It does glint!
Ah!
You can see it!
I see it!
Ah-ha-ha!
It's very, very slight.
Compared to the original?
Wow!
That's like...
That's crazy.
Crazy subtle.
I think...
Okay, hold on.
How do we get over there?
Oh, and it also gives you the clue with this.
With the reflection.
So if you don't see, you can see it barely shining just a tiny bit.
Wow, wow, wow.
Just, just barely, just just barely.
I like this other visual clue.
A lot, actually.
I think that's pretty nice.
Tree bark?
I'm desperate.
I want to get up on him, you know.
But he's pretty...
I don't know even if I can get over there.
Can I?
Maybe, though, we can at least...
Well, I have to hold him up three times.
Wait, where'd he go?
I think I went too far over.
Maybe, uh...
I don't know everything.
There's a lot of things I don't know.
And things I forget also.
Can I go to another area?
I got back from a party and was busy unlocking all the achievements for Delta.
Oh my gosh.
I think that dot is him.
There's no way I can shoot him from here.
You can camp up there.
You can go there.
go there on this map unless I can go down can I go down like
there's I don't think I can cross this I know Ryan need a trank sniper let
me try going this way we're all dirty and gross
yeah he's sleeping wow he's the loudest snorer ever
maybe that exit yes yes so we have to go where are we?
we have to go up to the left
hopefully he'll still be there and still be asleep sleepy sleepy old man okay but before we go in there I will change back to oh my goodness it's like a battle it's such a battle in here you know okay get rid of our footsteps i wish i did an audible like footstep thing too because i can't tell sometimes if my foot you know okay hey this works hey this works all right
but having this with erasing my footsteps is like Makes it super nice for this fight, I'd say.
Oh, a bad.
What is that noise?
I don't hear him, though.
Please, please still be here.
Sorry.
Cake jumpstick.
Wait, I thought I was down there.
Wait, I'm up here.
Wait, I thought I would be down there.
I'm up here.
Then he would be...
He would
be...
Oh my god, please!
We're just getting started.
You can't get me through the tree?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, this POV is evil.
The POV is awesome.
It's great, right?
Something slimy is in there.
Did he leave?
don't see the reflection anymore, like the little, I think he laughed.
Wait, nope, he's still there.
Oh, yeah, he's definitely still there.
He's 100% still there.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah, he's still there.
Can I get up there?
Oh, look at that.
That's so cool.
I don't think I can't.
Wait, maybe I can.
Maybe I can.
I think I can.
Yeah, you see him?
You see him?
Sparkling it up there?
Okay.
We gotta find a way up there.
If I keep close to the wall...
No!
Ah!
Oh geez!
Awww!
Eww!
Let him shoot again.
I at least got him.
Dang it!
That really threw off my whole plan!
I wasn't at all where I thought I would be.
Oh!
Ah!
Wait till he goes to sleep.
Pretty tasty.
Yeah, I think he, you know, now knows where I am, so will he fall asleep?
Wait, this is maybe good though.
We're kind of covering this area.
Actually, where am I?
Oh, how do I get up there?
How the heckie?
I'm just trying to figure out the map now.
It feels so different.
Like, I recognize it when I recognize it, but it also feels weird.
Kerothan on my left?
Where?
Right there.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where am I headed to?
You're up soon.
Those thermals aren't that bright except around Snake, so I think you've got to be staring at his cake to give play.
Ashbang.
No!
Why would I be doing that?
Why would I do that?
Weirdo.
Okay.
Oh, my bad.
Maybe he's not here.
I did get everything in here that I could, right?
Oh, oh, oh, they got more ammo.
Okay, it does replenish.
I was hoping.
I was hoping they'd say that.
Snake, you've been caught in a snare trap?
You're going to get yourself shot if you stay up there.
My bad.
Use the action button to cut the rope and escape from the trap.
Hurry before he finds you.
I don't think he's here.
I think he's here!
Why does this keep happening to me?
Is he running?
Oh my gosh, that's not what I meant to do at all.
I think he ran off the map.
I think he ran that direction.
I don't think he's here, JoJo's, if you could just...
Oh, hi.
Wanna grab you?
Why aren't the bunnies afraid of people?
Yeah, I think you went this way.
Oh, geez.
Why, geez.
Someone once told me I sound like Rick and Morty when I say...
Jeez, so I try to not say it, but I end up saying it.
I don't want to be that.
I don't know where to point in this map.
You know?
I think I know where Gakko is.
Has anyone seen my rabbit little...
This sort of fluffykins?
He was hopping around there somewhere.
What did he say?
I think I heard him.
I think I hear him.
Wait, his bird!
Wait, where is he?
I got his bird.
I got your bird.
Ah, there, there!
Ready for some more.
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
I didn't think he would see me.
Of course, why would I think that though?
Of course he'll see me.
Damn it, he recovered so much!
Oh gosh, this is tricky.
Holding him up is really hard guys.
I might just go for him though.
I might just like...
Shoot.
I might just try to get him.
Eat the bird.
Why would you say that?
And then my tummy growls.
You okay, Snake?
I did hold him up once.
No, it's several times in the original.
Oh, good, good.
It's starting to rain again.
Ah, I hate that he recovered so much.
Oh, shoot.
I didn't know he threw that.
Oh, my God.
I am.
I
think he could see me.
Pretty tasty.
Don't growl.
I hope he doesn't hear that.
That's so embarrassing.
Freeze?
Where did he go?
Oh, there he is.
How is he so much faster than me is what I wonder?
Okay, I really lost him.
How did I lose him?
Oh, wait, his foot jumps.
This way.
Take his camo.
Wait, did I miss it?
Did he drop it?
Uh, wait, where was it?
Oh, hi, Kero-Kan.
No, I don't think he did.
I didn't see it.
Hold him up for longer.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, shoot.
Is it this way?
I completely lost the...
Oh, oh, you guys.
You guys!
Now I'm lost!
Um, I lost where he went.
I think it was...
No.
Not yet.
Uh, well that's...
My fault, I guess.
I guess it's my fault for getting lost.
Yeah, he left the map.
I just... I saw where he went and I don't remember how to get there.
Was it this way?
Who knows?
I got one guy.
It's okay though.
I heard him.
And I also heard...
Is that him walking?
That's a goat.
I heard him though.
I heard him whisper.
Is he right in front of me?
No.
I didn't see, like, a text, so he's not that close.
Oh, he's asleep.
Oh, but where?
But where?
Oh,
I see him!
Okay, I'll hold him up for longer this time.
Oh, there we go.
Come
on, Grandpa!
Yippee!
Where'd he go?
I lost him again.
Why do I keep losing?
him i don't even see his footsteps wait no that's too much
ammo okay wow we where it gives photosynthetic capabilities extremely effective in areas
maybe we can get 100 yeah i also got to find this guy again I got it!
A good man is hard to find.
Achieve a camo index of 100%.
Yippee!
Nice.
I lost him, though.
I completely lost him.
Oh, wait.
What's this?
I think he went behind me.
But maybe his footsteps got...
Oh.
Unless...
Wait, that's...
That's him?
Just kidding?
I found him?
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's 100%.
Again, again!
I'm following, I'm following.
Or is that a goat?
Oh, that's him.
Oh, he couldn't hear me because it doesn't know where my footsteps are!
I thought it was another goat.
What if I just get him from here?
I'm following, I'm following, I'm following, I'm following, I'm following.
Wait, this fight is so great with the battle suit.
It's so nice, actually.
There he goes.
Bye, Grandpa.
God, he's so fast.
The fastest in all the land.
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
Wait!
Oh, there he is.
Yes!
This is!
This is the end!
How is it so easy?
Because I'm wearing a camo that makes it so that they can't hear your footsteps, so...
I kind of... That's like the real cheese, to be honest.
Spirits of the forest...
I thank you.
The boss...
Would be proud of you.
The time has come for a younger generation to rise.
No camo.
I got the camo.
What are you talking about?
You missed it.
I've been wandering for more than a century and now my journey Comes to a close.
Wait, I got that bird What a splendid way to end it all.
That's my bird That's my lodge I have no regrets I can return to the forest For him, I'll die.
Nice.
Okie dokie, now where was that?
Woohoo!
Wait, where?
There it is.
Gimme, give me, give me, give me, give me, give me, give me, give me, give me, give me, give me.
Nice!
Oh, wait.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh.
Beep, beep.
Oh, I guess we don't need this anymore.
I'll put this back.
Okay.
Woo!
I should have gotten some good pictures with him in the end.
Let's go back to being a crocodile suit.
Nice.
Now where was it?
This away.
This.
Okay, before that, though, I kind of want...
I'm hungry for some goat.
Anyone else hungry?
Ninto the best though, no.
No.
Paramedic, I caught a parrot.
What kind of parrot?
Yeah.
It's green all over with a large beak.
Then it's probably an Alexandrine parakeet.
It's sometimes also called the Alexandrine parrot.
Parrot.
The Alexandrine parakeet originally comes from Indochina and is distinguished by its green body and red beak.
Yeah.
It's very talkative and makes a good pet.
But it's strange.
The guide doesn't say anything about there being Alexandrine parakeets in that area.
I'm thinking it must be someone's pet that got away.
Snake.
What?
Don't even think about it, eating a cute little bird like that.
But I didn't say.
Just don't.
I see you caught a mark or...
I did.
The Marcore is a kind of wild goat that lives in mountainous areas.
It's quite large, so I don't think you'll be able to capture one alive, even with the tranquilizer gun.
All right.
The Spasa.
Speaking of which, do you know the origin of the name Marcore?
No.
It means snake eater in Persian.
Snake eater?
Lost your appetite?
Not at all.
So, how does it taste?
It's supposed to be pretty good.
All right.
Now let's eat this guy.
This is really good.
Oh.
Wait.
Look at his sleeping face.
Look at his sleeping face!
Look at his little face!
No!
How can I get down, please?
No, please.
Wait.
Let me in, let me in, let me in, let me in, let me in, let me in, let me in.
I had it, I had it, why did I lose it?
I wonder what XOF is thinking right now.
Please!
How do I go down?
Wait, what's the precision control?
Whoa.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
How did I...
Center off character off?
No, that's what it needs to be.
game screen is just like that.
I just I had it and then I messed it up.
Okay.
XOF exists?
Uh-oh.
Someone didn't play five.
It's okay.
Don't worry about it.
Art.
Oh, there we go.
I'm so stupid.
Thank you.
Yeah, it is.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh, my gosh.
You mean me?
Yeah.
Oh, I guess.
I think this is as good as I'm going to get it.
Go to sleep, little baby.
Go to sleep.
Little baby.
It's a little baby.
There's a little baby.
Snake sleeping face Snake sleeping face Snake sleeping face Wait I'm gonna have to I want to take off the face camel
Oh I can't because I'm asleep Never mind
Yeah I won't let me because I'm asleep Minto's creepy otaku laugh.
He's also sleeping in the survival, was he?
I missed it.
I missed it then.
Wait, is it...
Wait, I didn't see him standing there, so he was dead.
He was just on the ground.
Paramedic.
Yeah.
I ate one of those Spotsum mushrooms you were talking about.
about really how did it taste I passed out seriously seriously yeah so that's why they call it the bringer of sleep what oh I look the word Spotsa up afterwards and found out it means bringer of sleep in Russian well but anyway the reason the Spotsa puts you to sleep when you eat it is because it contains a type of anesthetic substance similar to an alkaloid maybe if you soak a handkerchief or something in it you could use it to put the enemy to sleep that's why i said i needed the anchor chip falling asleep might cause your life and stamina to recover as well why don't you find a safe spot and try it out ah that's why i said you need the handkerchief oh my goodness oh my goodness i love this game he's so like flat oh perfect have you considered making your own mgs lore or timeline video No!
The right person to do so.
Yeah.
I miss, I miss, like, I don't know everything.
You know, I'm not afraid to admit that.
Wait, where was I?
Oh, here it is.
So, Snake fell asleep in his resort mascot costume.
Yeah, there's so many details and I think, I think
I'm just not the right person to do it.
But that's okay.
I'm not like, uh, you know.
Wow, we've already gone through two bosses, you guys.
We're killing it.
And I'm killing this rat.
Come here.
Everything but the rat.
I know that there's easier ways to do this, but it's so much funny.
It's so...
It's so funny.
Wait, where is Agako then?
Where is Agako then?
Maybe he is at the top.
Are we gonna gate her on the ladder?
You betcha.
Oh, I can't believe we're here!
This is exciting.
I wonder what version it's gonna be if it'll be the original?
I wonder...
Yeah, if it'll be the original or the new one.
And then, if it's the new one, I wonder if you play Legacy if it's the original.
Let's see.
Searching, and I'll melt into you.
What a fear in my heart.
But you're so supreme.
I'll give my life
to you.
In my time, there'll be
no...
It's the way I flirt to you.
I'm still in a dream.
Snake eater.
I'm still in our dream.
Snake Eater.
Ew, ew, ew, ew, ew, ew, ew.
Woohoo!
Awesome.
Still looking for Gokko.
I must have really missed him, huh?
Hi, Doc.
Hot dog indeed.
Wait, unless he's here?
Wish it was twice as long, right?
What a thrill.
How?
Whoa.
This area.
We got birds.
This game was the reason I got a PS2 back in the day.
Love it so much, right?
Boss fight, ladder defeated.
Is it that three bosses down?
Oh wait, let me put my suppressor back on.
Okay.
I love that my camo is still 60 here.
It's kind of... 70?
It's kind of insane.
60?
60 when I move?
You think this guy's poisonous?
I wish I could get more ammo.
I kind of want to kill the guys here so the birds eat them.
Hug it.
Guys, I can never remember the difference between poisonous and venomous.
Would anyone care to explain to me?
Just a little explanation.
What's this hole here?
I've never seen this before.
The mountain croc, yeah.
Very dangerous in this region.
Poison as if consumed.
Thank you.
I don't think I've ever seen this hole before.
Where does it go?
Ah!
Am I lagging?
Just a tiny bit.
Exploration.
Do you think you saw my snout?
That was a close one.
A chaff, nice.
That was a really close one.
That was scary.
How close that was.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, I think I got his radio.
That's kind of funny.
Um, can I go down?
Making sure there's no one else.
I'm not feeding the birds today.
It's the way.
No, no, no.
No!
Also,
Sidorio, thank you so much for that!
Thank you!
It was honor to meet you today.
Thank you so much!
I'm sorry.
It was so, it felt so short, but thank you, thank you.
I can't believe... Ah!
Christian, thank you!
Welcome to membership!
Oh wait.
No, there's not.
No, no, no, no.
Why couldn't you be like this guy?
I'm almost out of bullets.
This sucks.
Sucks!
They're stupid.
They're so dumb.
Ah,
why would I?
Why did I stare at it?
My bad.
Sorry, everybody.
So sorry.
So sorry for the mishap.
So, so sorry for the mishap.
I hate this area.
Like, so much, actually.
And I become the Joker.
Here.
Why?
Where?
Think?
No!
What the?
Oh my god.
Did I get bit by a stinking spider?
My eyes.
Damn it.
No, no, not rotten food.
Food poisoning.
I like how serum doesn't...
It's a scorpion!
I hate this- Oh my god!
Oh my god!
Maybe I can get him.
With...
The cigarette spray.
Equip spray?
What's Lake Plasm?
What do I not know?
Nobody?
Oh shoot, wait, this is not the hole that I was thinking of.
HQ respond!
Where's the hole I was- where's the crawl- where's the hole?
Oh, no!
Um...
Oh, jeez.
Wait, they can see in here.
I'm hungry.
Okay, hold on.
Actually, I'm kind of getting hungry.
For real.
I got a parrot!
This bird looks familiar.
Woohoo!
Let's
eat the Mark War.
Mark War.
Hey, this works.
Yeah, this works.
I I'm just spraying smoke everywhere Ah Ah Ah Ah
HQ This is HQ Patrol here We lost sight of the enemy Commence alert formation Acknowledged The enemy is standing behind
Just a crack.
I'm sweating so bad.
Holy moly.
Also, sorry I'm lagging a bit.
You know what?
I'm gonna...
I think it's okay.
Let's just wait for the caution to go down.
All in favor of the caution going down, Aye, aye!
Okay, majority boat.
Oh,
yeah, we're gonna chill for a second.
Hmm.
We only have...
We have one more Sons of the Boss left.
Which is pretty exciting.
Hydration time, exactly.
Froggy!
Thank you for the gift!
Thank you.
Maybe I was getting a little over What's the word?
Optimistic?
I was optimistic About being able to use My Full self What are you?
Oh, I think
I was just optimistic About being able to use My regular My full self And the game
I wish I could hear the music except there's a stinking helicopter call
it off please respond this is hq patrol here the situation is normal understood return to your position do i have 12 cigarettes left uh-oh i might be in trouble i think it's time for okay i'm sorry crock i'm not good enough to use I'm not good enough for you,
Croc.
Where?
Who saw me?
Please, please go away.
I can't believe I only have three bullets left.
This really sucks.
This is really bad.
This is like so bad.
Yeah, you're just seeing things.
Like, I can't miss.
Don't miss.
Ah!
Oh!
I don't know why I don't use first-person view more often.
What's wrong with me?
Please, baby.
No!
I'm in pain!
I'm in Spain without the us!
Do people still say that?
No!
Please!
This game hates me?
Okay, that's a bush.
Not a person.
Oh, what's in here?
Wait.
Oh!
Wait, if I go into photo mode here...
Oh, because I'm like stuck in here, it won't let me...
Sweet baby.
I think a guy comes down here.
I just can't remember when.
Unless it's the guy I got.
Who knows?
Wait, another hole?
Please.
No!
One shot.
Enough to...
I could have probably CQC at him, but that's fine.
No!
Game, I'm begging you!
I'm begging you!
Shit.
The game is really...
Really...
Making it difficult for me.
I mean, this area sucks enough.
I don't want to be here.
And if I die, I have to do it all over again.
This ammo gotcha is funny.
Yeah, it's so...
Ah!
Ouch!
Excited,
requesting backup.
Ah.
Oh.
No, God, no.
Everything's fine.
I die, I die here instead.
This is way better!
These are the strongest, the strongest ever!
Wait, hold on.
Oh, but I don't want to die there.
Wait, so what I was thinking was I go back and I try for loot.
But I don't want to die there either.
Because then I think I died at the beginning of the map.
I love the powerful boxes.
I'm a fan.
I'm a really big fan.
Wait!
Wait, look at...
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Sorry, I'm doing this for Sonic.
It's for science.
Wow.
Oh wow.
It's for science.
Oh my...
Wait, what did I do to my arm?
Twice!
What did I do there?
It's the scarring system, guys.
Wait, maybe that's the fire.
I think that's when I was on fire.
oh look there's a bullet there's a couple bullet walls wait it's actually working
look the arrows yeah neat that peace walker outfit looks so good it's the ground zeros one as well right yep oh uh um we could go rambo style wait what if i just put on this and then we run for it wouldn't know how i got these guys i'm gonna run for it with my handy dandy knife wait what if i also did it
um we're safe in here i think i i need to turn around though i'm going further from where i need to go but i also i needed to be we needed to not be in caution Because Eva won't talk to me.
And she'll be like, ah, no snake.
I'm not opening up the door for you, stupid.
Eva won't talk to me.
She hates me.
Now we need to go up there.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha.
HQ.
This is HQ.
We've lost sight of the intruder.
Going into high alert.
I can go in caution though, right?
Or is it just...
alert I can't remember call zero for the heartbeat I didn't hack the thing I can't call for my own
you can during caution okay that's what I thought I was like I don't think you can during surprisingly my health is like so good though I don't know how I don't know how we made it everybody but somehow we did it what's a Better camouflage.
Chocolate chip!
Wait!
I want to wear this one and call Siggint.
Well, I think they'll...
We have many things with Siggint.
He might be like...
Siggint, the chopper we were talking about, is flying around.
Yeah.
The one at the heliport?
We should have blown it up.
Perhaps it's an armed variation of the MIH hip.
No.
Some of it looks the same, but the overall shape is different.
Yeah, I tried to blow it up.
stub wings and the cockpit canopy looks like an angular greenhouse sir it gives you the fury there must be some kind of new model i've heard stories recently that the soviets are developing a flying infantry combat vehicle that's got to be it a flying infantry combat vehicle a hind a transport chopper with carrying capabilities think of it as an attack transport chopper version of france's amx vci or the soviet bmp they must be doing field tests on the initial generation chopper that's a little smaller than the hip maybe we should call it a hind hmm not bad is cool with me then it's settled we'll refer to that new type helicopter snake your hind is not smaller than your hips oh buddy anyway the hind is armed with a 12.7 millimeter machine gun on the nose and rocket pods and anti-tank missiles on the stub wing hardpoints normally you'd be crazy to try and fight it on foot if it starts attacking with the machine gun or the rockets take cover behind something as fast as you can as for the
missiles you should be able to knock out their guidance system by using a chaff grenade to block the radio signal wait I have those I do I do I need to get let's see
I'm gonna get his ankles
With the snake call the fluffy accumulation of fibers on his freshly washed maid dress.
That's maid lint.
Anyways, guys, how are we doing today?
I'm peeking?
If we can go during caution, we might...
Might be okay.
If not, I hide in the hidey hole again.
Climb, please.
I saw something.
No, you didn't.
No, you freaking didn't.
Uh, wait.
The tried and true.
Happy to enjoy some Metal Gear Saturday on my birthday!
Takis!
Happy birthday!
Happy happy birthday!
This is HQ.
Thank you for the super time!
Thank you, thank you!
We gotta go, okay, hold on.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, we gotta go around...
I hate this area so much.
No problems detected.
I
like how for this, it kind of...
It's very similar to how it was in...
in V when you take on...
When you put on and...
Oh, nice.
When you put on and off the box...
Wait, can I get it?
My camera is like kind of stuck.
Maybe not.
Dang it, I wanted his little face.
It's so cute.
Alrighty.
We're almost there-ish.
Look at this!
Look at this bandana!
Why is- wait, bunny ears.
Snake has bunny ears.
Wasamimi?
So cute!
Snake!
I'm trying to get in there.
I kind of want them...
There we go!
Cute!
So cute!
I wish...
I could try stun grenade.
Or smoke grenade!
And I could like run up and CQC him.
Stun grenade might be safer, but people will hear it.
Chaff can cut off the radio.
Yeah.
I don't know if he comes up or not.
The guy that was just walking.
It's a mystery.
Oh, there he is.
Okay, it doesn't.
This feels a little tricky.
Spoiler.
Shaft and stun him.
Look at that bug.
Where did he go anyway?
Oh, there he is.
Okay.
just go behind them.
He might not be able to...
Oh, never mind.
Wait.
Do I have to go up here?
Uh...
Do I go through the underground?
Ah, I can't remember.
I'll...
Some universe.
I hope every time we sneeze is an obsessive cute girl.
Ghost girl taking photos of us because of this honorary fashion movie.
Do I
go down in here or do I, uh, I, uh, which way is it?
It's not that room right there, for sure.
No?
Yeah.
Um, so I can't read the map.
Just be safe to go through this pathway.
I think I'm 80% camel, right?
Let's... wait for this guy to leave?
Maybe?
It's to the right of that room.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like up there.
So I'm... I'm dumb.
How can he see me?
Blind?
Don't jinx myself.
Please don't jinx myself.
Please don't...
Okay.
I'm gonna go.
I don't know which one to use!
I don't think it'll hold him up.
I'm not sure.
CQC?
Yeah.
Damn
it.
Oh wait, I think we're okay.
Where the hell am I?
Ah, I need to go this way.
Okay.
Nothing at all.
Wait.
We must put on our best for Miss Eva!
No way!
Who dies
on the shoes?
No way!
Oh!
ma'am well that was quick it was you look like you could use some rest i'll be fine it's just that playing these two roles hasn't left me much time to sleep where'd you get those cuts it's eating it's like talking he found out if he knew i'd be dead already no this is his hobby he's a sadist he gets pleasure out of making people suffer he's scum
does it look that strange to you no i'm the same way scars all over can i see no
where'd you get this one i got it after defecting to the soviet union sorry i just i saw a tummy and It's older than that.
Code-breaking is a desk job.
Where'd you get this kind of scar?
You really want to know?
How'd you get those scars?
Well, too bad.
Hmm.
A girl's got to have some secrets, you know.
But enough about that.
You've got to get going.
The Phase 2 trial of the Shaggleheart is about to start.
And it looks like someone might be coming to spoil the party.
Khrushchev?
His forces are on their way here.
He looks so dapper.
If we don't get a move on, the security will be even tighter than it is now.
You'll need this key.
Oh, thank you.
It unlocks the door to the underground tunnel.
Once you're in there, you can follow the tunnel to get inside Groznygrad.
And take this too.
Robin!
What is it?
The food of the future.
A well-balanced meal for the space.
It looks like he's kissing it sometimes.
Oh my god.
Wait.
I'll bet if I kissed you.
You taste like a wild beast.
Do you know where exactly in Groznygrad, Sokolov is located?
He's in the heart of the fortress, the Weapons Lab.
The Weapons Lab is divided into three wings.
There's the East Wing, which houses the research facilities.
Then there's the main wing where the weapons are assembled.
That's where the Shagahod is.
Finally, there's the West Wing, which is connected via a passageway to the main building.
When Eva zips up her suit, it's like a reverse parry, the pilot was.
To get in, you'll have to enter the main wing from the East Wing.
Then, go through the passageway on the second floor of the main wing.
The West Wing of the weapons lab.
Got it.
Pretty sure he takes it.
It's like...
Crack.
Not again.
It's a load of crack.
The West Wing is protected by the highest level of security.
You need to be Colonel Class to get in.
Colonel Class.
Here.
Look at this picture.
Look at them!
Major Ivan Rydenovich Rykov.
Pretend you're him.
Wait.
How do I do that?
I'm sorry.
He's looking into Vulcan's eyes so like...
Steal his clothes.
Woo!
You look similar.
from behind they won't know the difference your face might be a problem so you just have to figure something out he should be somewhere in the east way gosh could you approve with a three hour oh gosh oh right but how am i supposed to escape once i get so glob out of there i love how he looks command said you're supposed to have something ready for me and i do There's a lake 30 miles north of here.
I hit a wig there.
A wig?
It's a state-of-the-art ground effect vehicle.
The ground effect?
I'm sorry, I know the screenshot effect is so annoying sounding.
That's okay.
I happen to be an excellent pilot.
Yes, ma'am!
Taking off from a lake is trickier than it looks.
It's not like riding a motorcycle.
You've got to be more delicate.
Of course I will.
You've seen how good I am with the bike, right?
Right.
You handle the escape, then.
I'll head for Groznikrad.
Wait a minute.
There's something I wanted to ask you.
I love every time the Croft hat goes...
What's the story between you and the boss?
She was like a mother, and my master.
And your lover?
It went deeper than that.
Deeper?
half of me belongs to the boss do you love her no nothing like that do you hate her does it have to be one or the other I'm too sad love or hate to laugh no between a man and a woman oh my goodness you bet never mind for 10 years we lived and died together you couldn't possibly understand and you think you
It like covers up everything.
Assassinating the boss.
Oh, this music makes me so sad though.
This music makes me so sad.
Snake, is there anyone you like?
Someone special?
I've never been interested in other people's lives.
I'm so sorry.
You were interested in the boss.
Stop, I'll stop, I'll stop.
She was different.
Really?
How do you feel about me?
I should be asking you the same question.
I can fall in love if it's part of the mission.
Holy moly, she's just...
Even with you.
Wow.
Snake?
his lips were so tender what's his what's the skin drop the skincare routine king
the crock cap stays on uh oh i'm okay
which one are you more jealous of take care of yourself what about you i've got to hurry back and play my Gosh, Evo looks great in this game, though.
She looks so good.
They're not stupid, and they know there's a spy.
I mean, I know she's beautiful in the first game, too.
We're original, but...
Good.
God, she looks so good.
She looks just like...
Oh, yeah!
Oh!
I can't stop laughing.
Crop cat off.
Crop cap on or off?
Off please.
Too bad.
We put on our suit?
It was enough to get her to kiss us.
Uh oh.
Baby's angry.
Baby rage.
Wait, I'm going to see him again.
Oh, it's been so long.
Nice shoes.
Can you talk?
No, he died before I could get it out of him.
yikes it looks like was it the spy then
oh look at this a transmitter exactly planted to keep someone informed of his location
but you can't handle the spy sauce does this mean glannon was the spy perhaps he was being used by someone else perhaps this man was our comrade comrade or not he's of no use to us now I don't approve of your methods I don't need your approval I'm in command here and that nuclear shell still feeling sore about that are you what What are you gonna do?
Report it to the authorities?
This is war, Major.
The Cold War, fought with information and espionage.
We must root out spies wherever they hide.
It is killed or be killed.
Potential threats must be weeded out.
Your feelings are a menace to the unity of our organization.
Someone is guiding the enemy's hand.
can only accomplish so much make no mistake there is a spy among us but casting suspicion on our own comrades see three explosives have been stolen you think it was the American no he could not have reached this fortress yet then who I'd be careful about suspecting boss such a lust for espionage where have you been Toilet,
the fear and the end have fallen.
Baby rage, baby rage, baby rage!
CIA dog, that leaves only the fury.
Oh yeah, I know.
How can the legendary Cobras be beaten so easily?
He's good.
Oh, God!
Look at him!
Fallen for him.
Ah!
Don't worry.
I'll take care of him.
What is he after?
He must be more than just so long.
America is out to destroy the Shagohad and get its hands on your inheritance.
The Philosopher's Legacy.
Impossible.
The Legacy.
It...
It what?
Then they're out to kill me as well.
Boss.
Colonel, tighten the security on this place.
I just noticed she has like a mole under her eye.
He's coming here.
I'm sure of it.
I'm gonna get the Davy Crockett.
Fallen for him.
Why do you have to say that, huh?
Tatiana, you're so beautiful again today.
Steph, Steph.
Steph, Steph, Steph, Steph.
Steph, Steph, Steph.
Snuff, snuff, snuff, snuff.
Perfume.
Hmm.
What's wrong with perfume?
Smells like crock.
It's not perfume, it's cologne from our suit.
Nice boots.
Make sure you polish them up properly.
Yeah, maintain your image.
I love the way she makes fun of him.
It's so good.
Goodness gracious.
Is anyone else sweaty?
Okay.
I think they could see me from up here, so I gotta be careful with my outfit.
Now I select the main character, baby.
What am I?
What new item did I get?
Oh, key B.
Open the door in the east of the mountain top.
Do I have my binoculars?
No.
Oh, whoops.
Oh, my God.
Wait, the croc sticks out.
This little beehive.
That's so cute.
Where's my binoculars?
I
wonder if you can see guys from here.
Oh yes you can!
Wowie wowie.
That's where we're gonna go get our crotch grabbed.
I'm excited.
Are you excited?
Yippee!
guy?
Literally just one guy?
Get one guy to Grosdy Grub?
Where's everybody else?
Huh.
I think there's two.
There are?
Well he's really well hidden.
You little booger!
Major Zero, I'm trying to hide in my cardboard box and the guards keep finding me because of my massive croc booty.
Wait, where's Gako then?
Gako, Gako, Gako, Gako.
Unless he is behind me!
I'm gonna get out of this area though because it's making me lag.
nice delicious snack yummy yummy yummy there should be some more under the bed yep nice oh I forgot that I'm basically like out of watch out for that guy um I forgot I'm basically out of ammo what did I just grab
I don't think I nope nope
Am I going to be able to fight the Fury?
Yeah, I got mo's an ammo.
This is not good.
This is quite bad.
Oh, wait.
I need to, of course, I need to leave.
You look up, you'll find keratan.
Oh, no, that's gako.
Wait, is there keratan in here?
Oh, wait, because, yeah, this is technically another map, so...
Wait.
I can get it.
Bakero time.
Time to hold up every guard, you see, for more gotcha.
I'm nervous, but if I die, I die.
It's okay.
Let's just go.
How do I get...
That was...
Okay, to get to where I need to go, that's the place I saw before.
No.
That's a different...
Oh.
I can't remember this area either.
I'm so bad at remembering sometimes.
Um, we could hold up everybody.
We could do that.
80 camo.
Let's go.
85 when not moving.
Wait, now they have the flamethrowers, though, right?
Oh, there's one.
Yeah.
Yeah, now they have the flamethrower.
Nice.
Nice, nice.
Yeah.
I could hold this guy up, maybe.
Let's try it.
If I die.
I die, baby.
If I die, I die.
Wiggle for me!
Oh, like you just don't care.
Is the achievement I just got?
Come on!
Wiggle!
Wiggle.
Dance for me.
Dance?
Nothing there.
Uh, nothing there?
Nope, nothing here.
Nothing here.
Yes, you are.
Ah, that's that right there.
I think this is where I need to go.
No?
There?
Hold on.
My eye.
I might be able to just run for it.
We're running for it.
We're doing exactly what I said we would do.
This is not where I need to go.
Um, guys, I made a mistake.
Wait, where am I?
That's not at all where I need to go.
I was a liar.
I can't remember at all.
Why don't you do your own video on where...
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
I gotta unlock it, though.
Please don't explode me.
Oh, okay.
We're fine.
I don't think I'm gonna be able to do the Fury, though.
I'm nervous about this.
I'm a little nervous.
Unless they give me some more.
Right here.
Okay.
Here.
I think the game hates me.
For real.
Oh, we haven't tried this one.
Oh, wait.
This is the poison one.
Whatever.
wait we'll eat we just got some more incidentals we'll eat this i want some more i want some more we could see qc punch him that is an option
please bandage wait then they're like you're getting burned buddy there might be some
yes finally okay we're good we're good We're good.
We're good.
I was gonna say there might be some down there, but we're good.
Whoa, it's cool.
You can, like, actually see down there.
That's fine.
Okay!
Uh, we should be fine.
Wait, I wish I could remember how to reload, though.
Cool.
I remember.
Did I miss the ladder scene?
Yeah, unfortunately.
Oh, night vision.
Yeah, let me put those on.
Thank you.
Yeah, we'll put those in.
We'll put those in.
I have a feeling this fight...
You know how, like, with twin snakes, Vulcan Raven is very much easier.
I have a feeling this will be the same.
especially with the peace walker outfit i think it's gonna be not so bad
alternate cutscene pov with really wait so if i equip them
let's see we look like uh splinter cell what's his name sam wait it looks so cool
Wow!
Wait, it looks so cool!
Wait, we look awesome!
Sam Fisher, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sam, wishing I was fishing.
Looks sick actually.
I know!
Wow!
It's cool to see it from this perspective.
Like, because of course when you put it on, you always like, just...
See it from further away.
I love the furries I love I love
Still RNG heavy Okay cool I am The fury The flames of my rage will incinerate you So cool I came back from space As I returned I had one vision set ablaze.
And do you know what I saw there?
Right!
Fury!
No kidding!
A great and terrible fury at being alive!
So cool!
Now, you're going to feel the scorching heat of that horrible planet.
I can't see anything.
Here we go.
Was that him?
Oh my gosh, no way.
Oh, he really didn't.
Oh, I gotta rip his suit first, though.
No, I don't.
Just kidding.
I know how he goes.
My suit!
i love the music in this part too it's so good fury's a really good cool like last uh boss for this area you know or for like these guys
oh my gosh don't get burned don't get burned whoa the fire effects is awesome did he just dodge that
Holy cow.
Oh, that was close.
Snake, please move.
I'm in, like, the worst possible spot here.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
Thank you.
Oh, my goodness.
Cheers, Snake.
What the heck were you doing?
Hang on, BBQ.
Thank you.
I don't think you need night vision yet.
Well, I guess for the cutscene.
But I don't think you need it for the fight itself.
Well, I did up my brightness.
I'll say that.
I did up my brightness for the stream.
That was pretty bad.
That was pretty terrible.
Um, let's eat...
I'll get...
Let's just eat the noodles.
Equipping a box still puts out the flame?
It does!
Wait.
Well, I'm already, like, injured, so it doesn't really...
It's... we're just low health.
Holy moly.
I just gotta recover.
Recover, snake, recover!
I'm kind of in a really bad spot.
I need to do...
That
is what I need to do.
I'm not recovering very fast, but...
That's okay.
I could... Oh, yeah, actually, I do have some life meta.
Listen, do you guys think I should take it?
I'm scared of dying.
I haven't used it at all.
Just gonna keep crawling for now.
What's this?
I can't- Oh, damn it.
Nice, nice, nice.
Good stuff.
My anger is growing.
It's- it's- yes.
Wait, did I see him?
I don't know which direction he's coming from.
Oh, there he is.
I don't know if that hit him, actually.
I don't know.
Bats.
Freaking bats.
No, no, no, stay away.
There he is.
Bats.
It won't let me.
Look at the box!
I think I hear him right.
He's right behind me.
He's right behind me, isn't he?
Please not again.
Okay, okay, again.
We're fine.
Let me... I'm gonna eat some more food.
Whatever.
It's tiny, but...
This is so horrible.
Oh wait, actually that did a lot.
No pipes here?
Oh, hi, Kurodan.
He stresses me out when he does that.
Okay.
I think he's right there.
We'll put out some of these flames.
Where's he getting?
What's there?
Did he see me?
Oh shoot.
We running?
Gosh, this fight is still scary.
This fight is still scary.
The spider is still very scary.
I don't like it.
Booy!
Holy cow.
We're
like almost half.
Is he coming here?
I don't want to just stand out in the open.
Oh, shoot.
Dang it.
He's gone.
Oh my gosh, there's so much fire here.
Like, I don't feel like I can go that way.
All blocked off.
I know it's pretty tough.
Please.
I'm cooking.
Oh, I'm not on fire.
Fine.
Where are you?
I'm lost.
I lost.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, where'd he go?
Oh, there he is.
No, no!
Did I get him?
Yeah!
Wait, did I get him?
Is this the cheese?
Reload?
No, no, no, no, no.
Where are you coming from?
Oh gosh, okay.
I'm stressed.
I'm stressed, I'm stressed.
That was close, that was close, that was close.
Oh gosh!
No, please, please.
Ah!
No!
I'm so sweaty.
My hands are so sweaty right now.
That's not a lot.
Snake, get up, please.
Please put on the box.
Okay, cure.
Holy cow.
What?
Oh, wait a minute.
Bandage.
MGS4 Rose would be calling about stress right now for real.
I'm so sweaty!
Holy cow!
Oh my gosh, my health is like the lowest it could be.
I'm just gonna be eating all my food, I think.
I wish I could recover faster!
Yeah, I want the final meal snake.
It's calorie made.
You might even have to eat the parrot!
Okay.
He's not even close either, which is...
Which really sucks.
Oh, gosh.
I'm so low.
Don't get hit.
I'm, like, really in a bad spot.
I'm really, really in a bad spot.
That's it.
Uh...
Let's fool it around, Snake.
Snake?
Snake!
Fooling around, he says.
Oh my god!
Oh, we're right into it!
Okay.
I thought it would be before the cutscene.
My mistake for...
Thinking I would have a moment.
Wait, that didn't do anything!
They didn't feel that at all!
Don't walk into the fire, Snake.
Wait, where'd he go?
Oh, there he is.
Oh my god, I thought he was...
I meant to switch back.
What the hell was that?
What was that noise?
I have an edge on my nose.
Yes?
You're stressing me out, man.
You're stressing me out.
Magnus!
You're stressing me out!
I think
he's gonna come down here.
Having trouble seeing you.
No, not at all, actually.
What about you?
Seems like you are, old man.
I'm literally the pain of my existence, this stinking guy.
Oh, was there a stutter?
Sorry.
What's here?
Oh.
I wish I could do this legally.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
No, no, no!
Where the heck is he?
I missed him?
I think.
Actually don't know where he went at all.
Oh, I did get it.
Okay, good.
Oh, was he above me?
My bad.
I heard him.
It sounded like he was so close.
put these out you're gonna get me I
tried to please get up snake snake get up snake
struggling a little bit wait uh struggling hold on uh wait uh I'm trying ah sorry hold on I'm shaking so bad hold on hold on my moment oh my gosh I was like what am i trying to do what am i trying to do um i forgot i what i did not check if um okay we do we did get the life medicine back which is great i'm gonna eat the noodles
take a second to calm down that's what i'm doing the coffee is like starting to get me so shaky you know the coffee plus fear plus adrenaline and everything
shake it out i shake it out yes yes
okay okay bra dog the noodles no we have water from the pipes and we have open flame Oh, yeah, yeah.
20 years later, Fury is still the same.
I know, my God.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, he's coming.
Where is he, though?
Oh, my gosh.
I don't know.
Where am I?
Ah, shit.
No, please, take it up.
fire anymore so I don't think I got him that time which kind of sucks oh
I'm not doing enough damage nice dodge thank you I'm not doing enough damage which really over here you don't know where I am do you
oh it is my anger is growing
I thought he was right behind me he's right in front of me
Go, please!
Dang it, I didn't get him at all.
I tried.
I tried to sneak up on him.
This guy is so hard.
The indicator for, like, the water pipes is really good, though.
Like, the bright red.
It's really good, especially if you've never played the game before and don't know that you can do that.
I wish this would go out.
I'm kind of trapped.
I need to get some good hits on him.
For real.
Shoot pipes for water.
I don't think it hit him.
So frustrating.
Oh my gosh.
Shoot the pipes for water.
Me 20 seconds ago.
Wow, it's really nice that the pipes grow red so that you can shoot them for water.
I'm going to use a cure.
I'm going to use a live cure.
I don't care.
I'm going to use a live medicine.
I only use them for boss battles and we have...
have a handful left now that I think about it oh wow we do actually have a handful of them left
stupid ass my dumb ass
please let me hit you
please this guy really does have the this guy really does make my rage consume me this spot, but it's also scary.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
This fight is hurting my throat.
Hold on, I'm taking a cough drop.
It's so hard to see him, too.
A
couple of good hits.
I like this area.
It's out in the open.
It's scary.
but you can get some good hits on him
you know
please stay excited get up
um he's like so aggro right now he's like crazy aggro right now
that's damn good that's damn good show him the emotion you carry into battle unleash the freak
I don't think that hit him.
That's so messed up.
Wait, I don't think that got him at all.
That's actually so messed up.
Did it?
It did?
It did hit just a tiny bit.
It looks like his bar didn't go down at all.
I'm gonna have to take another life mode.
I'm gonna have to.
We're running in circles.
Holy shit.
Please.
First try.
This is the end of the coax.
You've got to live on.
You're the only one left.
I'm off.
I took the chance.
Join the shot.
chance baby
behold the flames of fury the fires of hell will purge me clean see you there I
can see it mission control do you read me I
See the earth?
Snake run!
So awesome.
Ooh, it's smoky.
Oh, it's a rat.
Oh, here.
Ointment.
We were on fire!
Thank you.
Thank you!
We have one life med left, but...
Fury is a tough guy, so I think we'll be okay for the future stuff.
Maybe.
I'm still a little bit laggy, I apologize.
I almost went without his camo!
Oh my gosh!
I almost went without it!
It's like, what was all that for?
Reduces damage from flames and explosions by half.
It looks good.
Oh my gosh.
But I don't think red is snake's color.
I definitely think like a...
Like a blue is his color.
I think.
And I thought my pain was bad.
Why are you?
Did I get him?
No?
Where'd he go?
Where'd the rat go?
Is that him all the way there?
Oh no, he's right here.
Come here, little rat.
Where'd he go?
It's like my favorite thing to do is just...
The animals.
Because he's so aggressive about it.
He's so serious.
Oh, there it is.
Ah!
We finally got him.
Ooh.
They all right, computer?
Uh-oh.
Computer is like...
Unity plus VTube Studio plus V-Bridgeer, plus streaming...
Ugh!
Come here.
Okay, I give up.
Did you turn off wallpaper?
Would
you look at that?
The frames, they're back!
Yeah!
Thanks.
I don't want to know what my computer is looking like right now.
Nice.
Guys, we made it to Grozny Grad.
We made it.
Where Croc?
Hold your horses.
Croc is coming.
I do love the Peace Walker suit.
It just looks so good.
I love it more than the sneaking suit in this game.
Guess it was something random and unavoidable.
Peace Walker looks awesome.
Yeah.
There is no such thing as Peace Walker slander in this household.
Can I be a croc?
Wait.
Oh, I forgot to click.
The answer is always yes.
Game hates me.
What else is new?
of you.
I don't know if I'll walk over here.
Who's that?
Radio.
Where's our backup?
I'm a crocodile!
HQ respond.
Patrol here.
Enemy sighted.
Requesting backup.
Bam.
They didn't see me go under here.
Maybe they did.
We
made grave mistakes.
Oops, I looked right at it.
My bad.
So sorry, everyone.
There's like something kind of magical about just looking at you, don't know?
It works on one...
Oh, no way.
It went on one guy.
Guys, I think I might need to restart this area.
Oh, I thought I was really...
Wait, here we go.
It's, like, so close in between the legs.
So close.
Chomp, chomp, chomp.
Oh, wait, this looks great!
You can see everything!
Chomp, chomp!
No, no, no, no, no, no.
There we go.
Okay, back to our regularly scheduled programming.
I'm gonna redo this area.
I'm gonna
and redo it.
Wait, they really don't know where I went?
Wait, I don't think they know where I went.
Wait.
What do I need to cure from?
Oh, burns?
When did I get burned?
There we go.
Thanks for the fine gifted.
Ducky, thanks for the gifted.
Oh, did someone raid?
Hello!
I'm so sorry!
Hello, hello!
Where did that come from?
I don't know, man.
Oh, really bad bug bite.
Really bad bug bite.
Ooh, so...
biting our ankles i might have made it out of this this is hq how is that possible control here we've lost sight of the intruder going into high alert
wait why are they both like exclamation point the back guy over there i'm just a crocodile with a knife
i can make it
Nice, more...
What do you mean?
What's wrong?
Okay, where are we going again?
Right, we need to go inside, and then we disguise ourselves as the scientist, and we go find...
Rykov, and we steal his clothes.
Yes, yes.
That's what we're doing right now, everybody, in case you forgot.
Okay.
Are they walking down here?
I see one guy.
Right now, I'm kind of gathering supplies, but I'm also waiting for these bozos to leave.
You did not see me.
They're such on high alert.
I'm doing the espionage stealth stuff.
I'm playing the game.
Did you hear me change my clothes?
There's no way.
There's nobody here.
Yeah, nobody here.
Nothing here.
That's what the kids say, right?
Where am I, anyway?
Oh, there we go.
Oh my gosh.
They're not going to come over here, are they?
I wish I could drag them under the car.
Can I grab your toes?
Oh, he looks like so comfy, though.
Wait.
Oh, I thought that was a movie.
You know how, like, some of the guys have a secret theater?
Tapes.
I haven't bothered looking at any of them, I'll be honest.
Oh, I thought that was a person.
We're almost out of caution.
Oh.
I could climb the ladder.
Oh, no, I could not.
What's wrong?
He's not going to see me under here, is he?
Oh, okay.
Can you imagine if he, like, opens his eyes?
Like, oh, looks directly at me.
No, the caution went back up.
You know what?
I'm going to try getting on the roof once they leave.
Three of you, get out of here.
What are your toes doing?
Leave, are you cold?
You're shaking.
I could have drank them, I suppose.
Probably if I had done a stun grenade, it would have been good.
Oh my gosh, you kidding me?
I don't care, I'm going.
This is HQ.
Patrol here!
Climb!
Uh, where do I go?
I see you!
Scientist!
I'm a scientist!
I'm a scientist?
How's your first blind playthrough?
Um...
Whatever's going on out there has got nothing to do with this crack.
Woo!
They do know?
Um, hello?
Snake, that door can't be opened by normal means.
Apparently it operates by responding to a specific radio frequency.
If you want to know the key frequency, why don't you try asking someone nearby?
Uh, not the time, Eva!
Watch this.
No, I'm a scientist, please.
I'm just a scientist.
I'm going to go hide in the bathroom.
I need
your face.
I need your face.
Can
I have your clothes, please?
Oh, hello.
Don't mind me what I'm doing.
This is average...
This is very normal behavior for...
for Rykov, you know?
This is like super normal behavior for him!
Don't judge him!
What he does with his life!
What are we doing here, huh, everybody?
What are we doing here?
This is who he...
Whoops, my bad.
This is who he wants to be.
Let's cure a little.
Do you think it's the blood that makes it look like I'm not a scientist.
Do you think it's that?
Or, like, what can I improve?
Oh, no, I did not mean to use that.
Disinfect and bandage.
I'll have another one.
Ha-ha, crazy.
I'm bleeding.
There we go.
Snake, you okay?
He's looking a little...
Wait, go up?
There we go.
Beep, pop, beep, beep, brr, brr, brr, brr.
Oh, are they coming in?
Oh, I meant to take off my camo.
There we go.
Looks so good.
You're looking a little bony.
If everyone's asleep, no one can bother us anymore.
I see him.
Human!
Oh, a scientist?
An actual scientist?
I think the crock hat?
You're so right.
Okay, we're gonna start taking our boy over.
I wish I could carry him on my back.
How did I miss?
Hey, he's right in front of you!
How could you miss?
Oops, I think I got the...
Alright, scientist.
Chill out!
I don't want anything to do with you.
There we go.
This is how you do this mission?
Real.
This is how you do this mission.
For real.
Who's there?
I like how the whole thing lights up.
Uh oh.
As long as we get to the lockers.
We'll be okay.
Hey!
I'm working here.
Stop yelling.
Help me.
Nobody's coming for you, nerds.
Is it this one?
I could have sworn it was him.
Oh,
you need to be out of alert?
No kidding.
Can't during alert.
Okay, okay.
We're patient, people.
Oh, my suppressor.
No, no, no, no.
Oh,
my gosh.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Damn it.
You reset my timer.
Oh, I can't hear it, though.
It was the last guy, yeah.
Easy peasy.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
I'm going to see his tidy wadies.
his tidy speed oh oh oh wow he's so smooth wow he's so smooth he's so smooth shaven hi riding
wow who's his waxer
okay now we can do whatever the hell we what baby no one will give us any problems anymore
look how cute i heard i heard gako
save check i think this game is actually quite good about like you know okay No open.
About saving.
We're all good.
Don't worry about it.
Thank you, though.
Yeah, auto saves really well, so it's nice.
It's nice.
Oh, but the paramedic movie conversations, you know what?
That's so true.
It's been a while.
Actually, I don't think I've done one at all today.
We'll do one right after this.
Let me open these first.
And then we'll save.
Saluting the locker for being a great security vessel for stuff.
Oh, a proper ration!
More suppressive.
This is great!
Wait.
Ah, I keep... There we go.
Okay, now we can do it.
Can I see his...
Snake Cove, what do you think of this?
What is...
Look at the convenient sensor.
Wait, it makes it sexier.
Because you can't tell that he's wearing a thong.
It makes it way sexier.
You can't tell he's wearing a thong, so he just looks booted naked.
A new thumbnail?
Wowie!
Hold on.
I want to like...
It's from this side now.
From this side.
Thank you!
Okay, maybe this works.
Oh, look, wrong button.
To quote Half-Life, Booty Shot!
Booty Shot!
It's hard to...
Oh, wait.
Oh, my goodness.
Wait, I want to up the brightness a little.
Wow, he's so smooth.
Do I need to call HR for harassment?
No.
Ah,
yeah, sniff him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can't get a good shot.
I'm concerned.
Don't be.
Okay, let's get him up.
All right, come on, come on.
Come here, baby.
Come here, little girl.
Come here!
Why did I call him like my cat?
Okay.
Oh wait, I can't- oh, I can't change it?
I can't change the camera at all?
This is still good.
This is good, isn't it?
To quote Metal Gear.
Oh wait.
Oops.
That's a loop.
Another ration.
We will take it.
I know.
It's an emotional quote.
And I'm using it in such a disgusting way.
Yeah, this is Ryden from Fortnite.
Ryden Metal Gear Solid 2 from Fortnite.
It's just trees?
Someone call paramedic.
I'm laughing so hard.
I can't breathe.
Just trees.
Well, now that we can do anything that we feel like, we can be a little freakazoid and nobody will judge us.
Not that that was ever going to stop me, but...
Wait, I'm stupid.
What?
Wait, oh my gosh, it's so exciting to see Rykov crawl.
Not crawl, but like, oh, we got the handkerchief.
We can see him, like, crouch walk.
He looks like a real gremlin right now.
He looks like a true gremlin right now.
Okay, now everyone's gonna love me.
Team, are we still awake?
This is your boss speaking.
Hey, nerd.
It's me.
Yeah, shiver.
Shiver.
Shiver at my sight.
Look how close he gets.
Oh, did you hear that?
Somebody's hungry.
This is horrible.
You gotta pee yourself?
Nothing unusual is happening here.
What's wrong?
Oh my god, wait!
Oh, he's just a sleepy guy.
I love having full rain!
I'm doing anything that I want!
Salute me!
Um, you were not fast enough.
I thought he... I thought I knocked him out of bounds for a second.
You are so welcome.
This is what it's like on Mother Base, too.
Thanks for that, boss.
Salute.
You were not fast enough.
What's going on?
It's me!
Don't question my authority.
Full on antidotes.
Get up there.
Stop.
Bandage.
I do need more of those.
No, please.
Stop it.
Climb.
Climb up.
There was something else.
No?
Just kidding.
Hello.
No, thanks for opening this, actually.
Room that...
Scorpion.
Room that they were like, you need the magic code to go in.
Or a man that will do it for you.
So you think this woke up something in Snake or I mean, we know what wakes up in Osalot very soon.
Sir.
Thank you.
You know what?
I'll leave you alone because you let me into the room.
And then we were in here.
Wait, what's this?
Mousetrap I don't think I was able to grab it before
Anybody peeing I wish what I wanted to do was put on the Rykov mask When you see Rykov because I love his reaction He's kind of like
Cute Cute
Salute me!
Yeah, that's what I'll do to you if you don't salute me.
Gamer.
Nothing here?
Nothing here.
I'm starting to get hungry, but we're approaching the point that I wanted to stop at, or rather I wanted to get to at least.
We're almost there, so...
Um, we have a quite, uh, we have a bit of a long cutscene coming up.
You know, also raid pantry or ammo sheds outside.
You're right!
Before I go, you're right, you're right, you're right.
We have some of my favorite cutscenes in the whole game.
I wanted to get, um, to... what's it called?
Uh...
past the torture scene like you know when he wake up in the jail so wait where am i oh here we are wait i'm looking around we'll just grab whatever i can find
is this a door any snacks around here no
is this one it's not lit up so i can't tell them
i wonder what's inside nothing but probably a bunch of rats Pantry's on the other side.
Wait.
I'm just, right now I'm just looking for any sort of items.
Anything just lying about.
No, no, no.
Other side where, though?
Sir.
Hello.
I'm starting to get really hungry, actually.
Oh, here we go.
No, climb.
No.
Climb.
Oh my gosh.
Climb!
I saw...
Stop!
Climb!
There we go.
Oh.
Nice.
That should be good.
We got some food.
I might go grab.
What should I have as a snack?
I don't even know what that's for dinner.
You do remember you'll lose all of this, right?
You don't lose calorie, mate.
Those are all...
I grabbed calorie, mate, and ration.
Those won't expire at all.
But we can eat the things that will expire.
Well, this one...
I'll eat it.
I'm gonna puke.
I said it was supposed to be good.
I've had enough.
Oh, he's referring to a certain event.
Ah, so then is.
We'll get it back eventually.
That's fine.
Don't worry about it.
I will eat all the things that will go bad, though.
This is horrible.
Calorie bait.
We'll eat a calorie bait.
I want some more.
Okay, let's go.
I like how you can still see him, sir.
What?
What did you say to me?
Keep up the fine work, sir.
Yeah, that?
Fine?
I think it's great work, actually.
It's amazing work.
Fine?
Fine.
You're asking for a death sentence, aren't you, buddy?
Fantastic work to you!
I might be on a bit of a power trip.
Wait.
Oh, it's not doing the camera angle.
Like the cinematic one.
But it is cool.
We can just look at it.
Wow.
That's her.
That's the Shagohad!
In all her glory!
We'll mimic it.
I like how you can still see the little men working.
I'll be a little man in there too.
She's pretty.
Okay, do you guys think?
No.
If I walk over there...
And then somehow...
Change before the cutscene.
Do you think it would work?
Keep up the fine work, Minto.
That's amazing!
Sputens- I messed it up.
I messed it up.
How am I supposed to get him?
What the hell?
How is Keto time?
Anyway, we're going to forget that happened.
Cheat.
I hear him going, Gako, too, over there.
Riden on it.
Not Riden.
Sorry, Rikov on his tippy toes.
If anything, there's a Keto, Gako, and film in this room if you want to mess around.
Oh, wait, I see the film.
That's it right there on that guy's...
Right?
How do I get it?
No!
Damn it.
Alright.
Oh well.
It's fine, it's fine.
I don't want to reload.
I don't think there's a way.
You can count on me.
When will you guys mod me into the game?
I don't know anything about that.
I saw some people already doing like GTA models and stuff.
What are you?
kill me what's the matter I know nothing I swear it whoops no one but the Colonel knows of the legacy I see don't she's just being a hot girl oh boy you don't have very many eyelashes left kiss of death she's
so hot
this part's not healthy enough for hot girls it's me you're the man from the CIA I mean to what are you doing here I told you before didn't I I'm going to get you out of here a man of honor just like your commander but I'm a afraid you're too late too late too late don't tell me the shagahods exactly the final preparations for phase two are complete uh-oh so glav what exactly is phase two to put it in technical terms it's a composite range extension system for medium range ballistic missiles say that like i'm 12.
The Shagohod was originally designed as a tank that could launch nuclear missiles from any type of terrain.
We bought you as the Shagohod?
Oh my gosh, yes!
There was just one problem we couldn't figure out how to solve.
Wait, you just want me on all fours.
The ICBMs we have today are simply too big for the Shagohod to carry.
Happy crawling like a...
But the military would not hear of it.
They demanded a weapon that could launch a nuclear missile directly into the American homeland.
That is when I came up with the idea for phase two.
She's so cute.
But there's no way you could load an ICBM onto the Shagohod.
So how'd you do it?
By accelerating the Shagohod itself.
She's gonna go fast.
In phase two, a rocket booster unit is attached to the frame of the Shagohod.
This design is so bad.
The unit incorporates the same technology used in the Vostok rocket that sent Major Gagari into space.
Compared to what Granon had, it's just so bad.
The Shagohod can achieve a land speed of over 300 miles per hour.
That monster can go more than 300 miles per hour.
It's still cool though, yeah.
As for this state of accelerated motion, it launches a nuclear missile.
It's just you need a runway to use it.
The Shagohod acts like the first stage of a rocket.
Yes, precisely.
The range of the missile launched by the Shagohod.
look how much increases from 2500 miles to 6,000 miles 6,000 miles that's enough to strike anywhere in the United States not only that with the Shagohard there's no need to construct giant silos like the ones used to house ICBMs all you need is a runaway about three miles in length all you need is three miles and you can launch a thermonuclear strike against any location in the United States from anywhere in the Soviet Union.
It cannot be detected by spy planes or satellites.
It's a mobile fortress capable of deploying in secret and launching its payload at any time.
A weapon from hell.
A completed prototype now sits in the hangar.
At present, it is the only one of its kind.
But Vulcan is planning to mass-produce them based on that prototype.
And deploy them all over the Soviet Union.
Yes.
And that's not the end of it.
He's going to ship them to Eastern Europe, to Asia, to all the countries of the Eastern Bloc.
Even worse, he intends to use the Shagohod as bait to format armed uprisings among dictators, ethnic insurgents, and revolutionary groups throughout the Third World.
His funds are nearly limitless.
He could start mass production tomorrow if he wanted.
The reason that tensions between East and West have settled into a cold war is because each side fears the other's power deter you just don't get it I don't the idea of using don't get me wrong I love the shagohad it's just kind of silly but the shagohad goes far beyond the level of threat it doesn't have the range okay that's true that's true that's true if such a weapon is unleashed on the world it will not be long before all nations are engulfed in conflict the Cold War will end and the entire planet will be consumed by the fires of war is better you're right you're right the Shagohod will be at the center of it all the little pot it looks it looks like something out of peace walker so you see it's already too late no it's not too late what do you mean we've still got a chance all we have to do is destroy the prototype and the whole facility before they can mass produce it exactly but just tell me what i need to do to destroy this place
all right the liquid fuel used in the rocket engine is stored in a tank if you can blow it up somehow some c3 ought to be enough to blow the entire hangar to smithereens c3 you mean that cutting edge plastic explosive it could be molded into any shape the bomb of the future where can i get it there was some in the armory here but it's gone now it was stolen by a female spy who was here a minute ago eva no that's not her name her name is tatiana she made her way in here by becoming volkin's lover oh my god i thought she was your lover wait we get to see his wife no she is volkin's lover This is my lover.
Would you love me if I were a Shagohat?
She's so ugly, wait.
Who are they?
My wife.
And daughter.
They're in America.
Now I remember.
Your family is in the custody of the CIA.
She looks like Nosferat.
How long has Tatiana been here?
Only a few weeks.
A few days before the Virtuous Mission then.
she said that Khrushchev sent her what did you just give her I didn't expect the picture to be so high all of the experimental data for the Shagohod please it is essential that you destroy the Shagohod I will but first I've got to get you to safety no I'm not going oh I'm so glad my mission is to rescue you leave me I see why snake had nightmares about vampires.
Khrushchev has abandoned me.
I cannot return to my country.
I would most certainly be sent to the Gulag's.
I've been waiting for that the whole screen, you guys.
Yes, I once thought of that.
Oh, I'm so happy.
My family's waiting for me there.
She looks like my tour feels so impressive.
Even if I fled to the United States, I would once again find myself creating weapons of magic.
Mass murder.
144.75.
In the end, it doesn't matter where I go.
I am still a weapons scientist.
Okay, I ought to come.
To be honest with you, I'm tired.
Every day I help create things that should never be used, things that should never have existed in the first place.
Every day, without sleep.
Without a word of praise from others.
You're doing a good job.
And my creations do not even benefit mankind.
They are merely the tools of politicians.
All I wanted to do was build space rockets.
But it was not to be.
The space race between America and Russia became the prey of politicians.
The space race and the arms race are one and the same.
Missiles, rockets.
What's the difference?
Scientists are always being used.
Please, watch over my family.
That kid's got her nose.
God, it's so scary.
The mask is so bad-looking.
Oh.
Major, what are you doing here?
I've been waiting for you in my room.
Excuse me.
Excuse you.
The grip.
Who are you?
Don't play dumb with me.
If you think you can fool me, mistaken I know the major better than anyone else I come here looking for Tatiana and what should I find it look like Vulcan grew more hair in the side greasy free-booter oh gosh
took him down easy uh-oh you just had to come and ruin it.
Look
how it makes no expression.
It really just looks like a mask.
What is this fairy disguise?
It's gonna rub off on you.
And then you'll lose sight of who you really are.
Not a fairy, I'm a ghost.
Stay out of this.
Everyone gets their ass handed to by the pod.
so great I see why they call you the boss what was that some kind of judo no it's called CQC a basic form of close quarters combat she's so cool he and I developed it together she's so cool she's so cool I'll take it from here are you but first I get that wound on isn't it I will make him pay for hurting Ivan bye-bye
time to watch his brain chemistry alter again oh boss is so conflicted Oh, I still watch.
Oh,
all the blood on the ground.
Is that his or Sokolov's?
Oh,
my.
It could be both, right?
Standing is crazy.
That's how I felt like during the Fury fight.
Just wombo comboed.
So bad.
Still want to stop on you.
I never said a snake.
At least Volga doesn't know about the Ivan picture.
Tell me.
Stop it.
Who have you been talking to?
He doesn't know what you're talking about.
You'd better start talking.
Please, stop this!
Who is Khrushchev's lap dog?
How can you do this to him?
I know you gave the data to someone.
I'll never do it like that.
You monster.
I can like, you can hear him moving around the room.
It's crazy.
I guess he's dead.
That's what I said!
Rip Sokolov.
Now then, I hope you'll prove more entertaining than he was.
But first, let's take a look at your body, shall we?
My body?
Yeah?
Mm-hmm.
Oh!
you've certainly seen your share of battles do you like what you see consider yourself lucky I am about to show you what hell is really like well then let's get started what is your target is it the Shagohod or Sokolov or maybe it's the me.
Answer me!
Who is helping you?
Who let you in here?
You're a tough one, but even you must have your limits.
And I am a patient man.
Oh my gosh, Acelot.
I can't wait.
where the fun really begins.
My body carries an electric charge for 10 million volts.
Let's see how you like this.
Wait, I forgot it zooms in.
I forgot the zoom in his L2.
How much does the CIA know?
They're after my legacy, aren't they?
Your real target is the Philosopher's Legacy, isn't it?
Oh my god, isn't it?
Oh, sorry.
Yes, yes.
Let yourself go.
That's what I want to see.
He's changing.
He's like, I think I enjoy all the torture.
It's no use.
He's not going to talk.
He's been trained not to break.
Trained by me.
Admit it.
Or after the location of the legacy.
Now you better not say it out loud.
The secret fund established by the three great powers during the two world wars.
You better not say where it is, if you're villainous, strange.
100 billion dollars.
Divided up and hidden all over the world.
Oh, that's what the Philosopher's Legacy is.
And you're looking for a record of where all that money is hidden, right?
You don't know that it's underneath my pillow.
No matter.
The Philosopher's Legacy is safely in my possession.
In the underground vault of Groznikrat.
Oh, okay, cool.
Oh, okay.
You'll never lay a finger on it.
Oh, thank you.
What's this?
A transmitter.
Who's responsible for this?
I am.
I planted it on him to keep track of his movements.
Ah!
Why?
He's going to smell it because it was on his body.
If they knew where he was going to be, they wouldn't have gotten themselves slaughtered.
It pains me to do this, boss, but under the circumstances, I'm afraid I must ask you to show me some proof that you and he were not in collusion.
You don't trust me.
Is that it?
Not that.
But he is your apprentice.
what do you want me to do i love him let's see i love all these stupid characters they're all so great cut out his eyes i don't like those blue eyes of his fast step for a big guy yeah he backed up fast you made him a soldier and now you will unmake him yes it'll make for a touching display
Do it!
Ruin him, just as he did the Cobras.
Oh,
sick!
He's such an asshole.
No, you need to watch.
Woman!
The other one, the other one!
Stop!
What is it, Tanya?
He's suffered enough.
Well, well.
Why are you protecting him?
Dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot.
That smell.
That smelly smell.
That smelly smelly smells.
Tatiana, you're the spy.
I love this.
And, so right.
He's so, he's like an alien, trying to act human.
I know that smell.
Yeah.
Stop it.
Taking a fancy tour, eh, us a lot?
No, I have no interest in this woman.
In woman.
In women.
I want to test her.
He has no interest in women.
Bro is a weirdo.
He's like, I'll let this be the judge.
He's so weird.
Do as you like.
He's just the weirdest guy ever.
Here we go.
You smell like crock.
Yeah!
The double slap.
There.
Satisfied now.
Well, that was refreshing.
That's a red cheek.
Come, we're going to my room.
So you survived the colonel's torture, eh?
Watching this has made me realize something.
I'm really into torture.
It's really not that bad.
It's the ultimate form of expression.
Yeah, bite his finger off.
Oh, he is so great.
You got lucky this time, Ty.
Tatiana.
Send them away.
Boss, what are you doing, boss?
Oh,
God, that...
One, four, four, one, four, four, seven, five.
Am I lying?
One, forty-four, nine, seven, five.
I've prepared an escape route for us.
Go out and head west.
Okay.
Pass underneath the connecting passageway and go north.
You'll find an open manhole there.
You're quiet.
No, I'm not quiet.
I'm evil.
The door at the north end of the sewers is unlocked.
You can use it to get outside the fortress.
I've got your equipment.
We'll meet up later.
Okay.
Eva But I can't get too close to yourself You'll have to figure a way out of there yourself Okay Just give me a fork and I know what to do I'll be in touch
She's got a meeting In
Bolden's territory
Wait Wait
Do I save and quit?
Is that what it is?
Okay.
Wait.
Time to eat.
Okay.
Call paramedic.
Yeah.
Okay.
Ready to save, Snake?
Johnny.
Snake?
My mouth hurts.
I talk poor god did you get cut up it feels like someone shoved me under a lawn why did she say it like that do me a favor tell me a story to take my mind off the pain snake have you ever heard of Renfield is that a movie it's the name of a character he's locked up in a cell waiting for the master to return eating the spiders that crawl along the walls change the channel he waits and waits for ages finally just as he's beginning to forget whether he's human or not The master comes for him,
saying the time has come.
Renfield is overjoyed.
Wait, isn't this?
The master spreads his huge wings, and a gust of wind fills the cell.
Come on, I don't want to hear this.
And there, standing before Renfield in human form, was...
Dracula.
Exactly!
If you stay there too long, your old buddy Dracula is going to come and get you too.
So you better start thinking of a way out of there.
You better not leave me without someone to talk to.
please snake think there's got to be a way out of there I'll try okay just let me know if you start having nightmares about Dracula I'm trying to decide if I want to do it now or if I want to do it next stream like start the stream with guy
savage hmm good stopping point IMO I think so too I think we'll do it next time we'll start it off with it yeah yeah so we'll properly we properly saved and we will properly quit and then we will properly open up the game and be like oh my god and next time we will beat the game i only played for five hours today but i am quite uh it was a busy bit of a busy day for me so i'm gonna call it there i'm quite hungry as well Hi!
Wait, my vision!
Try Princess!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
So I guess we'll just load a return to the main menu.
Thanks for the stream.
Thanks, Salty Zero!
Thank you!
Yeah!
Wait.
There we go.
Um, so yeah, next time we'll finish the game.
I want to do secret theater.
I want to play some people monkey.
So we'll do all of that.
I guess, uh, I do want to play sooner rather than later, but maybe I'll stick to Metal Gear Saturdays.
Maybe out just for the sake of my own nostalgia.
Good night, good night, good night!
This game is so fun!
It's really crazy seeing all these scenes in such high def and everything.
It's so crazy to me.
But...
Oh.
Should we one last snake eater?
Nah, it's okay, we'll just do it at the beginning.
There we go, thanks for the pig!
I'm gonna get going because I'm hungry!
I'm hungry, I'm hungry.
And next time, too, the eye patch returns.
Finally, I can wear it again.
I can wear it.
I can wear it again.
Otsuminto!
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Have a good day, have a good night, and I will see you when I see...
Oh, Spank!
Thanks so much for the take, after.
Thank you!
I'll see you when I see you next.
Otsuminto!
Bye-bye, bye-bye.
Bye bye bye bye bye bye bye Jikido thank you Thank you Bye bye